for the first time
california is losing a congressional
seat new york by
89 people is losing a congressional seat
and we did cover this before
but it brings up another problem that
we're facing in this country
and i guess interestingly depending on
who you asked it's a problem and
probably a bunch of people on the left
would say it's probably not a problem
and we're talking about stagnant
population there's
millennials aren't really having kids
there's
for whatever reason and there's also
lower immigration
and this is resulting in now a dramatic
shift
in how they're setting up congressional
seats
but i'm not going to talk about congress
today we're going to just talk a whole
lot about
families men women millennials the
workforce it's kind of a chill friday
night talking about some of the most
serious problems that are affecting
this country and we actually have
someone who's
probably an expert on all this i'm gonna
let you introduce yourself so you can
explain it
all right well i'm melanie notkin and
i'm the founder of
savvy auntie it's the celebration of
modern
ant hood a media company focused on
women who
don't have children of their own by
choice like me by circumstance by
challenge
and love the children in their life i'm
also
the author of a book by the same name
and of a reported memoir called
motherhood which is about the women gen
x
older millennials daughters of feminism
who expected that we'd have
the um the husband and the kids that our
moms had but also
have the education and careers and yet
we may have the education careers but
many
are finding their match much later in
life if ever
and having their first child in life
much later
if ever we're gonna talk about all that
it's gonna be fun we got ian's
oh yes hello everyone ian crosson here
great to have her to be here melanie
good to see you thanks tim
and lydia in the corner pushing buttons
as she does i'm very excited for this
evening because i love talking about
culture as one of my favorite topics
before we get started head over to
timcast.com become a member to get
access to exclusive members only
segments if you just click this
beautiful big members only button you
can then go to the members area after
you sign up
and we have a bunch of exclusive
segments a huge library of content
so we have we have a ton of like bonus
full-on episodes even i mean they're
averaging like half an hour of
special content so definitely sign up if
you want to support the show
in the event we get banned this is the
place where you'll be able to find us
but we do have a bunch of new
and amazing shows planned coming up in
the future we're even setting up a
newsroom
it's gonna be a whole lot of fun and
with your support we'll make really
awesome stuff happen
i wanna jump to this first story which
uh look we we're gonna get into
the sense of stuff for sure but we're
gonna chill we're talking about some
an article you wrote four years ago
melanie so we have this
from the new york post childish men are
to blame
for women having kids late in life i
wonder if that made men really angry
at men or at you but let just explain
what is this article about
so as we know generally the writer
doesn't actually write the headline
so i would just like to say it or add
the photo
um i that was not the point of the piece
the point of the piece
is to say that pew research had new data
that found
that women are much more
focused on marriage and parenthood than
men are
and also more focused on career
than men are and women have to know
that they may not find the man that they
want to be with
as soon as they want to be with him and
that they need to consider
whether they want to you know look at
their fertility freeze their eggs
consider now these are not i haven't
frozen my eggs i didn't freeze my eggs
maybe they want to think about having a
baby on their own and save up for that
maybe they want to save up for ivf
so that was what the piece was about it
was never about
making men feel like they are not worthy
of women how did how did that come about
then how did they
make your article about that because
because that's how
headlines work i mean is it because men
by by virtue of what you're saying they
conclude that
men aren't focused on family and career
enough so they're calling them childish
men
was it a dude editor who was like these
men are losers
no and i love my editor my editor is
amazing
no but some men
uh did certainly get upset in fact there
was one
that decided we needed like a talmudic
track
you know treaties on this was an
hour-long
you know opinion piece on
how i was wrong even though he was
talking about the data that is pee
research data it did upset a lot of men
and that frankly upset me because i
actually love men and i love boys and
i'm a champion of men and boys
so and i don't think that men and boys
are
childish but i do think that
we have a problem in america whereby we
are so focused on girls and
women and their power and empowerment
that boys and men kind of fall into the
background
and i think that if we want to
enable women to have all that they want
we need to raise
boys and men up i don't know you you run
into trouble
when you start talking about this stuff
because even though right now
women are the majority of those
graduating college the narrative is
still that they're the minority and
they're in the weaker position
shouldn't we start getting rid of these
women's programs and start propping up
men's programs to encourage men to get
i'm not a fan of college by the way so
this is not a you know an apology or or
me now supporting it no no
but just for the general context
shouldn't these
feminists be like oh we gotta support
the minority and that's the men now
i you know i don't know that you have to
take anything away from girls girls
should
be able to reach their potential um the
problem is that we've forgotten boys
so yes girls in stem science technology
engineering and math
girls have to you know get equity with
boys and
wonderful fine not a problem with that
the issue is that
boys are falling way behind in literacy
and we don't talk about that
by age six boys don't want to read with
their mommy anymore because they think
it's too girly
and they don't want to read with the
family anymore because it's just not
something just not something that they
want to do and we
tend to again focus on girls in stem and
you know i'm a
i'm a toy industry expert i go to toy
fair every year and other toy events
and i remember i went to one once major
company
and they had dolls um
fairy tale princess dolls and with them
came books so this princess had this
book and this princess
and then we went around and the the
more superhero characters were just
the the dolls where's the book
what do you mean there's no book with
these right this was your perfect
opportunity
to engage boys in literacy this is how
you do it
they want to read interestingly the
assumption is that because
boys are in the in the privileged
position they don't need help
and from that we've created a massive
disparity and now
right it's a fallacy it's absolutely a
fallacy well so then the issue i suppose
is
how are boys supposed to catch back up
to girls by going slower than they are
or at the same pace
wouldn't you need special programs and
wouldn't you then need to take away
programs from women
you know i'm not an educator so i don't
know what we
would need to take away from girls and
frankly i don't think we need to take
anything away from girls
i think what happens that boys
classrooms are set up for the way girls
learn sit still
listen take notes behave yourself don't
move around
boys need to move around you know but we
then they get in trouble
and then they don't go back to class and
we've we've shrunk and recess so
boys aren't moving around when they have
the chance to move around
you know some kids even girls who have
you know some form of
add they need to move in order to learn
but we don't want kids to do that kids
learn through play
if you want to teach a child especially
a child zero to three
the best way to help them learn is to
help them play
so yes we need to help boys
the way we do it is to consider how they
learn
and we need to decide that boys
have great potential and if we believe
in boys
boys will begin to believe in themselves
and if boys believe in themselves
they will then go to high school and if
they graduate high school if they
graduate high school
they may go to college if they want to
and continue
whatever it is that they want to do or
no go to call not go to college whatever
it is we just need to give them the
chance
what do we do about men now though
in terms of uh not being career driven
not having families yeah it's it's it's
sad it's sincerely sad i'm sad for the
boys i'm sad for the men
um we have focused again so much on
women
that well women have become more
masculine
um because we've been told generation x
millennials that you know anything boys
can do girls can do better
and you know in the 80s women i was
there
women were you know shoulder pads pant
suits we had to be masculine
and we're taught you know now more
recently you have to lean in
at work you know you have to take on the
way that men work the way that men
succeed in order to be equal
to them and so women became more
masculine and when you go on a date
women no no i
i'm okay no i'll pick the place oh no
let me play let me pay
and then you've got the men who don't
feel like they're contributing
anything and men want to feel like
they're needed like they're going to add
value to this fabulous woman's life
and women should start to
become a little more feminine and
understand
that femininity is not weakness that's
the issue we have the same thing of
men means oh they're scary and it's
toxic and toxic masculinity if they're a
man who behaves like a man
and if a woman behaves like a woman well
then she must be weak and fragile and
no no there is more power and femininity
in fact it's true that i believe that
femininity is the one thing that can
bring a man to his knees
i've often mentioned that i think
feminism in today's day and age
is actually anti-femininity and
pro-masculinity
they like to go after what they call
toxic masculinity but the way i break it
down is
we often hear about like women must be
ceos you know we need more women doing
that job and that job
and while there are conversations about
having men stay at home with the kids
there's not a big demand for it the same
way so i i just i um
when did this happen where the the the
role
of the the maternal role just became
irrelevant to society and i don't mean
completely but to a greater
deal where now it's like no no the moms
and the dads should be in the workforce
and you know i don't know have childcare
we should now what's really fascinating
to me is
they advocate for like government paid
health care i'm sorry child care
guaranteed child care
and it's like shouldn't the parents have
some system where they take care of
their kids
instead it's the maternal role is being
shoved down and women and men should
both be in the workforce
sure well so to be fair today with the
economy it happens that often enough
both parents need to work so there's
that too so let's set that up
but but is that a result of women in the
workplace
it could be you double the supply of
workers the demand doesn't change
all of a sudden everyone's undercutting
each other's wages it could be
i'm not an economist and so i i don't
know that yeah i don't know if i can
speak to it but it could be and i've
thought about that myself
um yeah it's true that this this idea
that
you know we don't have enough women ceos
higher management etc
you know basically doesn't answer the
the question of whether or not women
want that
and it's not to say that women don't
want to reach their potential but their
potential isn't necessarily
in in the office and we've created this
narrative that women have to keep
fighting you know in the glass ceiling
and all this
not all women want that and that's okay
too in fact women have it pretty well
because a woman can
go to college she can get like a law
degree and
you know get married and have a child
decide you know what
i'm i miss my kid every time i leave him
and i just want to be home and i want to
be mom and my husband is
can afford to to take care of us women
have that choice it's extraordinary
and yet we talk about women as if we're
sort of always limited by the
quote-unquote patriarchy
um i i why do you think they have that
choice i kind of feel
like right now guys aren't on average
doing as well i mean that's kind of the
point of the conversation they're not
making
as much money they're not as driven i
think also
they're not as worried because they've
got all the time in the world as far as
they're concerned so
if a woman is you know doing well in her
career and she wants to then have a
you know family and have the husband
work she's got to contend with the fact
that there's probably not
as it's going to be hard to find a guy
for
for a few reasons one who's making
enough money to support the family
should she choose to opt out
who's going to be interested in women
who has a career even maybe the guy just
wants somebody
he wants a wife from the from the get-go
you also have the issue we have
uh our friend jack murphy comes in the
show quite a bit
and he talks about how he thinks guys
should go for women 10 years younger
than them
who don't do any of this get someone
who's 22 marry her and just get a
housewife don't worry about someone
who's got a career
so if you have that mentality how does a
career woman then you know have what
you're describing
so actually maureen dowd wrote about
this not bad in new york times in 2005.
how what men really want is their mother
and i agree
um and the problem is that
this generation were not their mother
gen x
was able to do things that our mothers
couldn't do
when you know women um who graduated
high school in the 50s
you know if you look at their yearbook
you know what they were going to be was
teacher
nurse nun secretary
those are her choices if you're jewish
you only had three
so you know what what were these
women uh what were what was gen x
millennial women gonna do once we went
to college
we did everything right you know there's
no reason why we shouldn't go to college
no reason why we shouldn't pay the rent
you know and then in terms of this
career woman thing there are no career
men
nobody accuses a man of of prioritizing
having a job over everything else in his
life
i mean i i always wanted to marry and
have children very much
so if i didn't have a career i mean you
basically be
you know paying my my way through life
as a taxpayer right
because i wouldn't be employed so you
know women have to
take care of themselves they have to
have agency but yeah
um so women do
men do want their mother and we're not
their mothers which isn't to say
that women aren't nurturing women don't
want to do this that women don't
want to nurture and take care of their
husbands and take care of their partners
i know most women do want that they also
though
want to know that if they're going to go
through
childbirth which can be fatal
that there's a man there who's going to
be there
and certainly if god forbid you didn't
survive that be there for the child be
able to pay for the child
and i mean this in an evolutionary
evolutionary way she may not be thinking
this literally
but yeah and so it is difficult and this
is why we have so many women
who are um the the new just newly
released data
a woman is the average age of marriage
for a woman is
27. just 20 years ago it was 25.
wow i wonder if uh
as jordan jordan peterson mentions
enforced monogamy are you familiar with
the uh
the term it doesn't mean what i think a
lot of the feminists thought it
meant like the government would come and
like force women to marry some in south
dude or something like that
but you're talking about you know women
want to be secure they want to know that
if they're going to have a kid
they're going to be protected or safe or
have someone to take care of them
isn't that what marriage did yeah that's
certainly what marriage did
and that's what right the idea is that
we should have a culture
to you know encourage boys and men
to look to marriage that's that's a good
thing and now
they're not really encouraged to do that
and
and partly it's it is you know certainly
so
in terms of the college graduation so 85
of college graduates now brand new data
are women
42 men so and women tend to want to
marry a man even if she's got
higher pretty you know she never has to
worry again about her income
she still wants to marry a man who's
married who is making at least the same
amount of money
and of course there aren't enough men
who have that potential
and it not even not even that uh so
there's another article from the new
york post which i i've talked about
quite a bit and it always gets me in a
lot of trouble with the feminists
women are struggling to find men who
make as much money as they do
and look when we have uh jack murphy on
the show and and we had a long
conversation about this
where he was saying that if you're a guy
and you're successful why would you find
a woman your own age when you could have
someone 10 right 15 years younger
so you're 35 you know you go for a 22
year old
dedicated housewife doesn't have a
career and for
you know i guess i don't put words in
his mouth but a lot the idea to a lot of
these guys is that
a younger woman who can get an older man
who's accomplished
successful has a lot of money it's i
mean it's a big leap in access to
resources
and societal status when you've got a
guy who's accomplished well connected
so if you have a woman who's say 30 or
in her 30s
and she's working you know a job she's
making maybe
65 70 000 a year working at a a
publication in new york city
a guy who's the same age who's making
that much money could probably easily
get
a much much younger woman because that's
a lot of money to a younger person
which i imagine must make it more
difficult for for women
yeah that's exactly right so what do we
mean it's like we gotta we gotta rock
and roll i guess
yeah yeah no that's that's the issue and
so i'm looking toward gen z
and whatever that we're gonna call the
next generation is that if we don't want
that to happen we don't want to keep
women back it's not like we want to keep
girls and women back from reaching their
potential
and contributing to the world what we
want to do is help
raise boys and men to reach their
potential
you uh you mentioned femininity earlier
and how it's it's one of the
things that can bring men to their knees
yes and i thought about um proposal
and how men proposed from their knees
exactly and it's like
when you're brought to your knees like
why why is that a thing is it because
they were so like broken and desperate
and
please be with me forever like please
don't like
is that why they're doing it from their
knees because they're like begging to
god which is the woman
it could be it could be i don't know
it's the same reason you know we see you
ever see that really funny video
where there's like two birds and like
the female bird looks kind of normal
just like a brown bird or whatever but
the male bird is like jet black
and it's jumping back and forth dancing
it's like trying to prove their worth
so when the guy gets on his knees
basically saying to the woman i
will never leave you i am on my knees
for you
so you will be safe with me if you get
pregnant
so you mentioned you know evolution a
woman who gets pregnant is at risk right
i mean
you're not going to be running you're
not going to be fighting you need
protection right and so the guy you need
to know that the guy
is going to stand up i guess the problem
arises in that we are
the apex predator we kill and eat
basically everything
and in cities the only predators are
other humans
so there's still a need for some
protection but also access to resources
is important now everything's kind of
changing especially with
you know um maternity laws you know so
women get pregnant they can keep working
and now a lot of companies are like even
if
once someone gets pregnant she can go
home she can stay home and we'll still
keep paying her
so i think that also we keep moving this
direction
we're going to keep removing the need
for marriage which is going to slowly
eat away at
families having children to result in
slow population growth
seems like it's just dominoes falling
over well in fact
there there is a rise in people living
together couples living together and not
getting married
and i don't have the um i haven't dug in
too deeply into it but
my hypothesis is again it's a buyer's
market for men
that a woman who really wants a baby
with a partner
and he won't commit she will acquiesce
to saying yeah no we're just we're gonna
live together because like it's cool
like no it's great i mean
really what do we need a piece of paper
for because
if not he's going to go to the next
person right
so and this is what's going on in campus
this is what the hookup culture is about
a girl will you know girls are you know
oh kids are
kids so yeah i am old um on campus
the the hook-up culture is because there
are so many more girls
than except for maybe mit than men on
campus
and girls doesn't mean anything no we're
just friends no no
but really what she's really saying i
bet is pick me
pick me like let me make let me do
whatever i can to show him how good i am
in bed
how much i love him how do i care about
him
but no no it's all cool no don't worry
about it women are acquiescing all the
time
and in fact they're acting like men men
are the ones who spread the seed men are
the ones
who have sex with a lot of women all of
a sudden women are doing it
and i you know i say you know what no i
women don't really want to have sex like
men they want to have sex
like women and what they're doing is
they are listening to this narrative
that in order to be equal to men
they have to be men and that happens
even when it comes
to sex with 22 year olds it reminds me
of
like similar things to what you know
jordan peterson talks about you know
uh women trying to be men it also
reminds me of
like jokes from family guy where they
did one where it's the woman trying to
finish
with all the guys desperately trying to
act like a guy as if that's what she
should be doing
right yeah it's uh not confidence
building
you know everything that's happening but
i i will mention one thing as
as for marriage the only the you know if
there was there was one message that was
i was smacked in the head with over and
over again as i was growing up is
do not get married you will regret it
who's
who said that to you married with
children a very the highest rated show
at the time my parents wouldn't let us
watch it yes a syndicated show
where alabama al bundy the main
character yeah
hated his wife they hated each other sad
but it's not the only
show i constantly you hear this all the
time from from older men
they call it the ball and chain now what
kind of message is that to a guy
then you look at divorce courts
i i i there was there was there was a
case i think it was in illinois
where a man and a woman were getting
divorced and
it was partly because of the woman's i
think i think was like drug addiction
it's been a long time since i've read
the story
the court sided with the mother who was
a known drug addict because
courts have a bias towards the woman and
then she killed her kids
yeah and so the dad who was a regular
working class guy begged the court
this woman has been arrested before she
does drugs that is dangerous
and they said we can't take a kid away
from from from their mother
and then she ended up killing them
because she didn't want him to have him
and then taking her own life like
overdosing
so when you hear these stories all the
time when you constantly hear about how
divorce courts what is it like 84
percent of the time favor the woman
what's the incentive for a man to to to
marry a woman
if all it means for him is that he can
lose
half of his life and still lose his kids
in the long run
why do it it breaks my heart i am
i've certainly dated divorced men and
i've heard chilling stories
my friend greg ellis his book is coming
out father's day or that week
called the respondent and it is about
his hellish
experience um of being divorced or
getting or
his wife springing i won't it's it's
literally i
paid like a thriller like it reads like
a thriller the hell
he has gone through and the hell that
men go through i think that for some
reason
everything needs to be equities
everywhere equality is everywhere but
when it comes to family law
it is so incredibly unfair to men and it
sincerely
breaks my heart and to your point it
doesn't help
women because it means that a woman
can basically i mean it's it's really
this sort of believe all women
you know idea philosophy in courts and
it breaks my heart because
men are wonderful there's many bad men
as there are bad women
it's not a i i men are fantastic and men
do so much for their families generally
so i'm i'm with you the but i think that
the reason why
you know men marry women is because they
love them
which doesn't mean that things don't
happen and that
you know people don't change or
circumstances
what have you right for whatever reason
people get divorced but i believe in
love
and i believe that a man is better with
a partner and a woman is better with a
partner
and whether that could be the same sex
the idea is that we are better
when we have a strong existential
spiritual emotional mental connection
with somebody
we do better in life and marriage is a
strong partnership
to do that now i have not married
not because i didn't want to i very much
i still want to
but i never wanted to marry a man i
wasn't in love with because every man
deserves to be loved
and i didn't want to be in a
relationship where i didn't feel loved
so i wonder though um
i i was reading well i was writing this
a while ago but i was also reading it
recently that
love in marriage is a is a modern
construct that marriages used to be
contractual more
more corporate than anything yeah you
had the dowry and it was basically
well you know marriages are arranged for
this that reason
and less so you know in in our culture
and going back to
the various cultures that make up the
united states but if you look at a lot
of eastern culture
arranged marriage very much still exists
because it was transactional
sure oh yeah and it was the families did
it i mean sir all the royals are
are intramarried i mean there's no
question
today we don't have to do that maybe
that is a benefit of
there are a lot of benefits of feminism
um and that women can now
live toward their potential we have the
opportunity to do more than
be only nurses secretaries nuns and and
teachers
not to say those are all great
professions but we can do more
the difference is that um
now i've just lost my train of thought
you just oh the marriage so but
if a woman wasn't making any money then
how is she gonna find a met like the men
would could just pick any woman this way
if it was arranged at least she was
safe like this was you know he we're
wealthy
you have your you know life standards
this man will
make sure that you have a we can do this
you're from the same class the same
religion the same
royal whatever it is so that's part of
it
you know people have this issue with um
with the disney
fairy tales which aren't really disney
fairy tales they're disney fied
fairy tales and you know talk about like
cinderella etc
well why is the you know why did the
mother die in all of them well the
mother's dead to show kids
first of all that mothers did die young
anyway they died when they were like 30.
um that these girls could be on their
own take care of themselves but
yeah but you know well she married some
prince i'm like listen here's the thing
she had no education no skills
no job opportunities what was she going
to do
the truth is a prince
pretty good deal so yes we have to think
about things that
historically people did things the way
they did them for a reason today
you know that's not what marriage is for
marriage is a partnership
i mean i have a cousin who's uh you know
been co-ceo
a fortune 500 company and her husband
work but not
anywhere near to that level it's not
like it doesn't happen that
you know women can be more successful in
terms of affluence what
income but for the most part you know
women want to know that the man that
they're with will also enable them to
reach their potential
as he as she would do for him not only
in terms of a job and career but also in
terms of
family in terms of whatever else that
they want to do i think that's the
i think there's there's an incongruity
there's an impasse
you've got i think a lot of men who
want just a wife like like you mentioned
they want their moms
yeah so this current generation is just
there's no there's not coming together
it's like it's
if if women are taking on masculine
roles if they're taking jobs
men you know to a great degree to a
higher degree
don't want that right so then it's just
so i was
stuck huh i i'm very much into
um when it comes to dating i tell
women it's okay to be feminine it's okay
no you don't have to pick the restaurant
you don't have to offer to pay
the man knows what he's getting himself
into he's prepared
we know what this is it's a dance and
it's okay now it doesn't mean you never
reciprocate
other way but let him core to you let
him get give him the opportunity
to show you why he's worthy of you
because that's what he wants to show you
don't say i don't need you to help pick
the wine i can pick my
you know what it's wine unless it's
chardonnay because i really hate
chardonnay
it's okay you're not good you're not
gonna die from the fact that he chose
this cabernet sauvignon
just let him do it it's okay he wants to
give to you
in fact a great way to turn man on is to
ask him to help you
i kind of feel like this a lot of this
has to do with
at some point there was a fracture in
our society that resulted in two
different factions i guess right we have
the culture war today a lot of people
trying to figure out if it's left versus
right nationalist versus
globalist or authoritarian whatever and
when
i when i hear stories like this you as a
guy
you never know what ideology the woman
holds
and so are you even allowed to make a
move on the woman as it is
so you mentioned the guys want to court
you well if you go to like a sports pub
you're probably going to bump into a guy
who knows nothing about critical theory
and feminism
it'll probably start hitting on you if
you're in a big city though and you go
to like a hipster bar
the guys won't go anywhere near you
because you're not allowed to
right so i mean you you look at that
video that went viral
do you see it was uh 10 hours of walking
in new york as a woman remember that one
oh yeah so some of these things
that were depicted as wrong was a guy
saying howdy or like
nice day or how how you doing and
and hello it's terrible that's if that
if that's
if if that's the message we're getting
from mainstream media then what guy is
going to risk his reputation his career
and then even if he does get married get
divorced at some point
and then just lose everything and his
kids society is currently being set up
in a way that is telling men to do
everything they can not to get married
and they're happy
no responsibility they can sit around
playing video games all day i think it's
bad for the spirit
and in the long term the purpose and and
you know of our society but i think this
is just another factor that's resulting
in the collapse
of american culture and western culture
yeah over i don't know what it is i i
don't want to say it's that we have too
much freedom or anything like that
that we can choose to just self-gratify
right you know we are a wealthy a
successful
country so we can play video games all
day we can drink mountain dew and eat
taco bell and have to worry about a
thing
i don't think that it's our choice you
know our ability to do to do these
things i think it's the pressures of
of uh it's it's man i i go back to like
what we were mentioning earlier with
doubling the workforce
in a short amount of time as soon as
people were like you know we should have
women in the workplace if they so choose
it became part of a movement that they
should be in the workplace right
all of a sudden then you double the
workforce
without increasing demand and everyone's
competing and wages are dropping
then they say okay we gotta have a
minimum wage to guarantee it but there's
still not enough jobs so then some
people don't have jobs
once that happens and everyone's wages
are depressed there's a lot of other
factors as to why it happens
you have all of these factors building
up over decades
that result in a generation of people
who
are not compatible in terms of long-term
relationships and families
yeah no it's it's depressing and it's
sad and
and i think that we are too focused on
the narratives of how
to be a woman means you know to be
president united states
to be vice president united states to be
the top echelon of everything
and i mean i all the power to every
woman and i certainly strive in my own
career my own life to be the
to reach my potential and i'm so
grateful to live in in a country that
enables me
um to do that but
the truth is different than the
narrative and the truth is
that most women become mothers most
women want to be mothers which
isn't to say that there aren't women who
are child free by choice and they honor
and champion the choice
everybody should do what they need and
want to do
the issue is that men are feeling and i
hear what you're saying
why should i get off the couch first of
all i can
sext her and because she likes me and
wants my attention she'll sex back so i
don't even need to take her out on a
date
right and if i take her out on a date i
mean she's going to make me feel like
i'm not a man because she's going to
like not
let me participate in i don't think
that's an issue no
no i mean it maybe maybe it depends on
generation you know so maybe
older guys really want that i i
me personally i've never really cared
much for if a woman was like i want this
i bet whatever i don't care
like right no no which right so
what women want so women modern women
want
old-fashioned romance now many feminists
will say no that's not true
but that's really what women want and
partly because they
are working so hard they
are working hard in their career those
who have careers right they're working
hard there
but also they are nurturers
so they're working on their friendships
and their girlfriends that
call them upset they're working you make
sure their parents are okay that their
siblings are okay their neighbors are
okay they
they do a lot because of their own
innate sense of taking care
of people and taking care of the
children in their life etc
and they want to know when they're with
a guy
that all he has to do is just say meet
me
at this restaurant at 7 pm
that that is like such a thing that
women want it makes them feel so good
so we got like i don't care if she picks
a place like whatever whatever she wants
like
i mean if she there's a place like
around the corner from her that you i
don't
no care it's funny uh it it's it starts
to sound to me like feminism
is one of the worst possible things for
women in the long run and one of the
best possible things for guys in the
long run
from a very like what's the right way
from a from a sort of mathematical
perspective
so guys used to have to work really hard
back breaking labor you know wiping the
sweat off their brow
covered in dirt going down to the coal
mines now
they've got women working to support
themselves so the guys don't have to
worry about
it anymore women are not have they're
not making the same demands of men in
terms of you know sexual relationships
it's just go on tinder and the guy
doesn't have to worry about it
so now guys don't have to work they've
got all the time in the world because
they don't have a biological clock in
the same way as a woman so they're
sitting back with their feet up playing
video games without a stress in the
world
i'm being hyperbolic sure but they're
women are working they're worried about
how long how much time they have where
they can
you know in order to have a family right
they're stressing about how to find the
right guy
and guys are just sitting there swiping
on tinder while they're watching you
know
porn yeah yeah yeah yeah
so they're swiping on tinder and
watching porn at the same time
yeah and they're like what am i worried
about right i've got friends
you know i grew up i grew up
skateboarding and all of these guys
don't care about anything they will they
will work a minimum wage job if it means
that you can have 10 people in a
two-bedroom apartment
so they can work only a couple days it's
a hundred bucks a month for rent and
they can skate the rest of the day
that's all they care about yeah and i
look at the
the guys who grew up in you know like
around me from my neighborhood and
everything
a few of them you know have families but
not by plan you know what i mean and
then everyone else who kind of planned
and worked and went to college
they're sitting back with their feet up
making tons of money they have careers
and they're not worried at all and you
talk to them and they're like i don't
know you know
when i'm 40 maybe i'll find a 25 year
old they're not worried at all
right right no and also because they
don't have a biological clock
and all of that and but you know you
are a prime example of a guy who decided
that wasn't enough
and you manned up your own life look at
what you're doing
right you're the guy who said no this is
not fulfilling
for me to only skateboard or sit on the
couch or
or tinder porn watch right you decided
that no i have potential i have great
potential i don't even know my
potential because i haven't even started
it yet
and then you did and you're still going
and you're still going
you're building a media empire right
you're a man
and that's sexy to women it is not sexy
for a guy to be sitting on the couch you
know it's
swiping on tinder women don't find that
appealing
and they're it works for him well it
doesn't it doesn't there's also a lot of
men who are depressed
a lot of men who you know unfortunately
commit suicide
a lot of men who are overdosing who are
aimless
and they're getting older and they don't
know how to get out of it
and i'm hoping one of the silver linings
of covid
is that many were forced to be alone
that there was no
other choice maybe maybe life needs a
little more meaning
and again that's where a partner a woman
or man in his life can help him
get there we've been talking a little
bit about the the rat utopia experiment
have you ever heard of that
no it sounds lovely i don't know i don't
know too much about it other than
um people have chatted us about it but
the general premise was that
they created the space where they put a
bunch of rats in this you know terrarium
kind of thing
unlimited food and water not a care in
the world no threats
and eventually they populated to a
certain point then they
started becoming they started changing
some stopped having sex altogether some
stopped eating some just started dying
i think some like started becoming
cannibals it was like a really brutal
once they reached a certain level of
crowding and population
weird things started happening in their
rat society i wonder if
humans have reached a point like that
and i think that's why people bring it
up
to where maybe the reason we're not
hitting families anymore is because we
got we got a ton of people on the planet
as it is
especially psychologically with social
media i in the early days i was like oh
facebook good i'm going to get all my
friends on facebook and then i'm going
to be able to i'll be able to message
everybody at once and then i can throw a
big party where i have everyone in my
house and then all of a sudden i had
like
170 people 300 people and i
didn't talk to any of them i was so
overwhelmed that's and that's like
one of the things i said happened with
the rat utopia experience there's like
crowd and areas just like in weird ways
but i wonder if what happens is you know
we used to have kids
out of necessity you know uh that's why
if you look
at less developed nations they have lots
of kids
because the kids do jobs right but now
we got washing machines we got
dishwashers we got stoves we got
clean running water in the cities so you
don't need to have kids maybe it's just
a
natural state of life where you find
this equilibrium point where
you just don't need to have kids so
there's no real drive to do it
no no woman no woman goes through
childbirth
because she needs it i mean that like
maybe because she because it's a
because it's not this is like she's
literally putting her life in danger
women have an and a
existential like in her body like
everything
not all women most women to have a child
we do you think every month
we have a violent reminder yeah it's
great of our evolutionary
you know role and it's not it's not the
patriarchy
that created menstruation right
but i'm not saying that like women sit
there and think to themselves like i'm
gonna have a kid because i need to have
a kid
i'm just saying that pressures begin to
appear to not have kids
one just once a certain level in a
population size or
amount of resources and then it just
becomes less feasible
for people to do that's definitely the
case for men i mean we used to spread
our seed to as many women as possible
and now that's been become taboo in
society so that's an example of
not overpopulating is it taboo
for the most part polygamy's kind of
looked down upon yeah but
promiscuity is through the roof but not
having children all over the place
definitely doing it i mean yeah i guess
you'd be frowned upon in any capacity
the old trope was that the guy would be
chased out of the farmhouse by the day
with a shotgun you know who was sleeping
with the farmer's daughter or whatever
all that alimony
well it was because you have to make
like shotgun wedding you know
you're gonna take care of this kid and
you've you've just committed yourself to
doing it
these days it's like swipe on tinder you
just sit there and you swipe non-stop
and then you do whatever you want and
it's encouraged
back in the old day like i'm thinking of
zeus you know all these ancient he had
like 40 kids and then he had kids with
his kids that like
because they needed to populate they
were like yeah well recovering from
those those are stories yeah but but
like did he turn himself into a duck and
then bang a woman or something
wow what a weird story
yeah maybe it was real maybe it wasn't
but i think that that behavior wasn't
so taboo as it is today and where so
whereas women have the burning desire to
have children
men have the burning desire to have to
spread their seed and we've had to kind
of culturally
subdue that because it doesn't mix with
modern day
you know society like too many kids
without fathers would be very bad for
society
well it's bad for the kids kids who are
born
with who don't have a father father
figure in the household are more likely
to be poor
more likely not to graduate high school
more likely to end up in jail
so men have a very important role in
society
and again it just keeps you've asked you
know well what can we do and
unfortunately
you know it's too late for the
millennial and gen x generations to
change that
although certainly men can stand up and
do better
and they can raise they can be there for
boys and even if you're not a father if
you're an
uncle or if you're a friend of the
family you could be there for a boy
and you can help raise that boy that is
such a gift to that boy because that boy
will grow up to reach his potential
if he has that but unfortunately
we have you know kids who aren't
growing up without dads and it just
keeps you know going around and around
the same circle
um so i look
again women generally want to be moms
not all women
women want to be moms and it is it is
devastating
when she's doing everything she can
she's doing all the right things she's
contributing to society
it's like she's doing everything she can
and i
agree with you that a guy who's you know
her
equal in terms of you know career
income what have you he you know she's
35 he's 35 he can easily marry a 25 year
old
what happened to her right so it is but
it's devastating to those women
the level of of i mean i've i
have grieved not having children i'm i'm
beyond hope of having children and so
i've moved on from that but
certainly i mean and it's and it's
elongated now because
it used to be that a woman you know hit
a certain age 40 plus or minus
she was no longer fertile couldn't have
children but today
let's say egg freezing well there's
still hope
or even ivf there's still hope all this
technology people will tell you oh but
my kids
my cousin's sister's neighbor had twins
at 45. still hope so what does that do
it creates this
longer time of grief for this woman
and it's really hard so i
i i'm again a champion of boys and i
think we need to go back and look at
education how we are educating boys how
we're
making sure that they have male role
models how we're letting them play
encouraging them to play
all of those things right i think that
we also on the men's side
need to be a little bit more sympathetic
to women
they're not desperate because they
really want to go out with you again
because they like you they're not
desperate because they want to have a
baby and they're 36.
they're women and they want to be moms
and that's perfectly normal and it
doesn't make them weak it makes them
strong
to be able to admit that that's what
they want and if you're a guy who's
going to lead a woman
on and just because you know you don't
really want i don't know well maybe
we'll try well maybe next year well when
i get a raise
you know what her fertility doesn't have
time for your excuses
so if you love her or if you don't love
her let her go
or get married and be a man
so there's a i guess it's a stereotype
maybe there's actual data behind this
i've not
read it that's men tend to be goal
oriented and women tend to be social
oriented
so a guy derives his joy from
accomplishing something that dopamine
hit whereas women
from social acceptance and i don't know
if that's true
but it does kind of play into the story
about how young women are becoming
depressed because of social media
they go on instagram they take they take
a selfie they post it
it doesn't get enough likes they delete
it right away and it does affect guys
but not as much sure i've noticed
something really interesting when i
when i watch skateboarding videos on
instagram i noticed that
there are a lot of videos of guys
skateboarding
and actually you know what i'm not even
talking about skateboarding when guys
take photos of things or when they post
things
it's an object yeah when women do it
it's of them of course
yeah so i even know female journalists
and it's the weirdest thing to me
where they're like on the ground in the
middle east and they're taking a selfie
of themselves with like the thing in the
background and i'm like
just show the tank like you know and
then what guys do is they'll post the
video of just the tank with themselves
not in it yeah
so i wonder if that also plays a very
serious role
and that the reason women are hyper
focusing on work is because
society because of what would be deemed
acceptable
and this is stemming from when you look
at news media
and cultural media the women who are
working these jobs
are mostly career women not all of them
and
then you end up with a tendency to only
get the positive social message from
women who are not married
who are working careers then telling
younger women
this is the right way to do it this is
what's great and because of the
social pressure they do and that's
perpetuating this
cycle yeah
there are no career women it's not like
women are choosing to have a career
women have to work
we do what else we supposed to do get
married at a young age i guess
and siphon off the man or have a
traditional family i'm not
i guess raising a kid's worth more than
money that's for sure but
it's not like they're choosing career
over love
marriage and motherhood i didn't do that
most women aren't doing that well what's
why what's stopping them from having a
relationship then
so my mom actually asked me this because
she and i were talking about millennial
women and why they don't really appear
to want to get married and or have kids
and i said mom we can't afford to
we can't afford rent where we were
living rent was like 14 or 1500 bucks a
month and i was like there's no way to
afford rent and also have children
unless you are both working and i was
like i don't want to do that i want to
be able to actually raise
my kids and that means like part-time
work or not working at all and being
like a stay-at-home mom
right it's very much a matter of money i
think you're right yeah no it is
how did how did how did the families do
it i don't know 300 years ago
we'd
the economy today means that most
most women and men have to work
what else are we going to do and
especially when a woman
why shouldn't a woman work why shouldn't
a woman have a career it's
and i don't mean this in the feminist
way i'm in the you know
traditional feminist way i just mean it
like why not you know that's not
feminism that's just being human like
why shouldn't she reach her potential
that doesn't mean that she like for
instance again me
right i very much wanted to be married
and have children i had
a baby name book when i was 12. i mean i
had planned my wedding in my
family backyard i this was what i wanted
and it didn't happen not because i
didn't want
it but if i didn't have as well like
when i was in my late 30s that's when i
decided to create my own company
because i didn't know if i was going to
have some legacy and that's in the end
part of why we have children we want to
know we're going to leave something
we want if it's not literal dna then
maybe it's some sort of intellectual dna
there's something we can leave behind
and so that's why women have
careers because they need to be able to
pay the rent etc and
and by the way if they do meet a guy
he's divorced because the 22 year old he
married really wasn't
exactly what he needed because she
didn't really
she was much more interested in her body
and her selfies than in him
and in helping him be the best he can be
and he then finds this
you know 40 year old woman who's amazing
because they're the same age and
actually share
the same conversations intellect
experience etc and
and he's okay well we'll have a kid
together okay but
where was she gonna get the money for
the ivf or for the eggs that she froze
i mean careers pay for things and part
of it is it it gives her a safety net
for her fertility it seems like a
tsunami i guess or or it's like
um because every single woman
and man are engaging in these certain
behaviors it's created a situation where
no no one person an avalanche is a
better word for it no one
snowflake can now break away if the
system were
that you know like it was way back in
the day where women would just you know
they're in high school and they're like
thinking about the guy they want to
marry or whatever
and then they got out of high school and
then sought to get married
the guy took care of everything i think
that
the avalanche started you know for a lot
for a lot of reasons
i think it's it's great that women you
know civil rights expanded women are in
the workplace women voting and all that
stuff
but it's i wonder if you know that the
pendulum swings
and you can't just stop it so it goes
entirely to the other side and now it's
well when women now have to work yeah
it's not you don't have a choice
right whereas back in the day it was
difficult for women to work so the
pendulum was on one side
it should have been in the place where
everyone could choose to work if they so
if they want to but now it's
you you have to work sorry and because
of that it's creating pressures that
make it very difficult to actually have
a family
and it's making it very difficult for
people to afford to have a family
because
well you can't just walk into the woods
with an axe anymore and build a log
cabin and have your kids
now everything's under control by
government regulation
so there's no get on a boat and go find
in a place where you know back in the
day and i mean like hundreds of years
ago
the dude would walk over and like stick
a piece of wood in the ground and be
like mine
yeah and then have a kid and be like
we're gonna live here there's water yep
yeah can't do that anymore
right and that's actually what's sexy to
a woman a decisive man and i mean that
sincerely
a woman wants a man who say
you i want you and i want you
this is how we're gonna live i have you
know savings and i'm buying this house
and we have this car and we're gonna now
women can say well i mean i
really prefer that car okay we'll get
that car i mean you can come to you can
negotiate
but a woman wants a man who wants her
is decisive about it is strong about it
where she feels like this is the guy who
isn't going to want to spread his seeds
so she feels safe and secure that once
she has a baby he's not going to leave
her
to go have a baby with somebody else
women want men who are decisive
women want men who are thoughtful
they're not
a holes right and
fun three things
so the question is you
again tim are a man
you have taken charge of your life you
are you get hit by the left by the right
and by the middle and by everybody
around it
most of the people don't even get who
you are what you're doing
you are you're like leading away
and others are trying to copy you be you
whatever it is because you're
so good at what you do yeah they stole
my thumbnails they did
i i believe that everybody does the red
with the bold and
they use the same font and everything
yep it works it works
and you're a skateboarder and you show
everybody how much fun you're having
i mean you're the kind of guy that women
want do you want to get married
i'm worried about uh the legal system
okay
yeah yeah but yeah i do pre-nups can
help
yeah but it's it's just uh
what's the point what do you mean what's
the point what's the point of marriage
well let's discuss what is the point of
marriage part of the point of marriage
is to have a partner
i mean do you do you
um do you
feel like when you have somebody
important in your life
that there's you have more energy you
have more incentive you yes you do
you're you're nodding yes everything
i would say all of the expansion
what people need to realize is that none
of this would be
would not be possible without allison
who was my girlfriend right
and she is effectively running this
business okay so
i sit around and people say like hey we
want to do this and i'm like
ask alison because i can look at a
camera i can talk give my opinions but
the paperwork the fine i i would not be
able to do it without her right
that's a true partner there was there
was like a wall
where a certain point it was like here i
am here's what i can do
and this is what we have and then
you you find that you know that partner
who can
help you and then all of a sudden it's
just like the wall exploded
and now it's just like we're grown out
of control it's amazing
you are one of the most fortunate people
in the world
to be as young as you are and i know
you're not in your 20s
but young i'm an old man i'm 35. and
to have found a woman who loves you
and just by her very being
and loving you enables you to be
twice the guy you are
that doesn't come across very that
doesn't happen often
you're very lucky and she's very lucky
that you understand that
and that you see that in her and i'm
sure
that how all the ways that she helps you
and and
and your life is like twice the life or
more
her life is twice the life or more by
being able to give you that
that's how she grows so i
i i don't want you to focus on
all the things that could go wrong and
unfortunately right now for men
it's tougher i want you to focus on all
the stuff that's going right
i'm envious of you i want that kind of
love
i want a partner and i've had those
partners unfortunately it didn't work
out for whatever reason
that's the kind of partner you deserve
kind of partner i deserve we all deserve
and allison deserves so i
i'm hoping that she brings you down to
your knees it's it's
it's more than twice as effective too
like when you have the right partner it
seems like
you do 10 of the work of what like what
you're doing becomes 10
of the next structure and she's handling
like 90
90 i'm not just saying you specifically
in this situation but like when you're
in the right situation
you end up doing like what your old 100
percent was
is now 10 of the new system which is now
a thousand percent of what
you were capable of before you're
building a world together you're
building a life together
you know there's this thing in in when a
when a jewish couple
more traditional jewish couple gets
married the bride
walks around her groom seven times
because that's the number of days it
took to create the world
she's helping him create his world and
she
is his world and he is her world
that's that's what life is about is
about partnership it's about building a
world
together and your world wouldn't look
like it does without
your partner without alison and i mean i
find sometimes i'm frustrated because i
know i could be so much more in so
if i had that partner and yeah i have
great men in my life
i have good friends in my life that's
why i champion men and i'm so
grateful for the men in my life
obviously i want a relationship and i
want marriage so what does marriage give
me
it gives me me you know my issue with
marriage
let me be pedantic for a moment is the
definition of the word
means to mix when you marry two things
you're mixing them
and i've seen people that lived together
for 50 years never never involved the
legal system and they're just a couple
that
live their life and love each other and
maybe even have kids outside of the
legal system
and then i've seen people go i want to
be married to
you they go sign some paperwork and then
they get divorced within like three or
four years
and it's so weird losing all this money
and what's real marriage
being to me it's it's mixing your soul
with someone
whether or not the law is involved i
don't really care and then there's the
church which is the whole religious
aspect of it
so i don't know that's that's my take on
it yeah look i'm
i'm not telling certainly not telling
people how to live their life
and i and i certainly i mean you know
for me
i'm not going to have children and and
please god i'll meet this guy
sooner than later i mean i don't need to
marry him
in that i don't need to have that stable
household for my children that i'm not
going to have
would i like to be married sure of
course
but right now i i want to partner but
when we're talking about
younger people who especially assuming
they want children
marriage is especially for the woman
feels much more secure
and i get listen i i get the family law
issues
i i think that marriage is something
that
can create tremendous value for the
couple
and that commitment and it is a risky
commitment
but commitment is something very
powerful it feels like our society is in
a weird hybrid state between
traditional hierarchical um i guess
essentialist
but and can and constructivist whereas
the woke left our constructivist
they want a clean slate they believe in
blank slate they you know get rid of all
the old traditions
and then have this equity society where
men and women are the exact same
a man can be a woman you know whatever
one could be a man and then you have the
traditional society
which is the man works the woman raises
the kids you get married it's
a it's a societal contract between the
two parties and right now
we're mashed in between these these two
versions of reality it doesn't work
you can't you can't have some people
believing some of these things and some
people believe in some of these other
things
and because of that we have a legal
structure
that disincentivizes the traditional and
it's moving
more and more every generation towards
the more uh constructivist i say
constructivist
you know of view as opposed to the
essentialist
for whatever reason that keeps happening
and it's likely to move in that
direction that's where it seems we're
going
now there have been uh uh pew put out
this data
gen z is ever so slightly more
conservative
than uh millennials yes but i don't
think that's because
they're having an awakening or gen z
realize something was wrong or anything
like that or
or they're rebelling i think it's
because conservatives in the previous
generation
were just more likely to have kids so
it's not that gen z
are becoming or you know are
ideologically more conservative
there's just more conservative gen z
ever so slightly
that's interesting than that you know
they're the offs right they're the
offspring of those more likely to have
children
and and exactly and even then they're
still
more progressive than their parents and
very much
as progressive as millennials only to a
slightly lesser degree
so you so if that's the case then it
seems like we're going to continually
move towards a future where
in two or three generations it's going
to be a bunch of
gender-neutral shaved heads blue
jumpsuits
no marriage you know babies born in pods
eat the bugs i hope not
seems like that's where we're going i
don't know i mean i i think
that's an era that's you know i can
that's the aoc
you know people shouldn't have children
in the environment and i mean this is
not
no i again there is something about the
human condition
that makes us want to find a partner
and have children with that partner
again not everybody
not judging anybody but for the most
part and we know this to be true because
for the most part it happens
so while a woman is marrying later than
ever and she's having her first
child later than ever it doesn't mean
that she doesn't want those children in
fact
the fact that a woman has a child in her
late 30s
even early 40s proves that she's waiting
for love
you know what's really interesting about
this women having children later and
later
the the biological clock of a woman it's
not identical for every single woman
and so a society that is telling women
to wait
or at least there's pressures to make
them wait i wonder what the effect on
future generations will be based on
these pressures in terms of selection
if you have a woman who if the average
woman
you know can't have kids pass to say 40
or whatever whatever the age number is
right
and then you know and that's and that's
based on a society where women are
having kids when they're 20 or 22 or
even young or maybe 18.
then you start telling women have kids
when you're 40. what happens is
the women who can do and the women who
can't don't right
so then the children of those women are
more likely to be able to have kids
later on in their lives
i wonder if the result of this might be
i don't follow that
so uh it's it's it's not biology if
they're having a child
at age 40 plus yes women at age 40
can have intercourse and get pregnant
and have a baby
but it's not easy and it doesn't
always happen so so it's not a
biological thing those women are having
their
their first baby at 40 plus usually
there is some help
well so what i mean is if there are a
hundred women
yeah and based on all of these women in
the previous generations the average age
at which
they you know it's like here's your lat
39 if you don't have a kid by 39
you're probably not gonna have kids by
telling all these women to wait
what i wonder if what would happen is
that say half of the women
as soon as they hit 40 fail to have kids
right the other half at 40
do have kids right which means the
children of those
women are also more likely to be able to
have kids around the same age because
they share similar genetics
no it's not because it's not genetics
meaning
it it first of all because she's getting
part of her genes from
her dad as well but no it's it's not the
genetics it's
every woman has a biological clock
and to your point yeah it could be 39 it
could be 41 it could be 35 it could be
23.
i just mean evolution right there some
kind of evolutionary pressure
created this time limit and that can be
changed by creating a pressure for women
to have children later and later in life
well what's happening is that
people aren't necessarily telling women
to wait women want to
so the women who have their first child
at age 35 plus
are likely to be college educated
so um and
we were discussing earlier they're
having trouble finding a man because a
man
has a choice to marry a woman who isn't
college educated
and or is college educated whatever
reason he can marry some he's many more
choices when it comes to women plus
there are many more
college-educated women who want
college-educated men etc
women are waiting for love they're not
waiting because somebody told them to
wait to hold on
i'm i'm not saying that i just mean
their societal pressures that exist
to what to to go well that times have
changed it used to be that women had
subtle pressures to have kids at a
younger age and get married
you know just before turning 20 or
whatever well there isn't any child
maybe that's what it is
if only there were societal pressure i
mean to go back to
jordan peterson and and um the uh
what do we call it for for enforcement
yeah
women you know were we was
women especially gen x and older
millennials sort of
were you know understood that well
so and so this this celebrity had a baby
at 45
had twins i could do that but of course
it could be donor eggs
there are many other ways that maybe she
had frozen her eggs now
i mean who knows right so and it's not
really the the truth
so women were neces women just didn't
have all the information
that they needed but again really i
don't know
women who are putting off having
children
when they really want children and they
have a partner
most of the women who aren't having
children at age 35 plus
are single in fact 80 percent of them
are single
they're waiting for love i want and they
choose love
no it's not a myth you're in love it's
not a myth look what it does for you
but can everybody have no and
that's what sucks according to the
greeks there were seven types of love
huh and eros being one of them that's
physical sexual love there's like agape
which is the love of the community
there's the love of family is one of
them um platonic love plato actually
that was actually an eighth type of love
plato was like it's a love of friendship
um and i could look him up now if we
want to talk about george parents for
children
what's it called when you have like when
you're when you have a bunch of cats
stork is that what it is love
children yeah that's your love like the
parental love for a child
yeah not the creepy kind of lover we do
need more words for love we do need more
words for love um i agree because well i
don't i don't need a man because i
you know i i i love my kids or i love
that
well really no it's actually i've had
women say well actually you know what
the truth is like i feel like a little
chunky lately and i don't really want to
like in the end like women really choose
love they want to be with a man
women generally you know heterosexual
women
love men and they want to be in love and
men want to be in love
so these guys got to start going for
walks
get off that couch stop playing video
games no more mountain dew or taco bell
or whatever
go for a walk start uh learning a skill
yo and when you cook for your girl don't
ask her what she wants
make something you like no no no let her
enjoy that with you
make something really awful and just
tell her she has to eat it tim's tim's
such a social engineer such solid advice
seriously we're going to make mountain
dew chicken this weekend i brought up
the seven types of love
yes there's arrows which i mentioned the
romantic passionate love of
philia which is intimate authentic
friendship then there's ludus which is a
playful flirtatious love
storage which is unconditional familial
love falacio which is self-love
pragma which is committed companion at
love
and agape which is the love of the
community empathetic which one of those
is like when you have a good dog
you know i think it's the love of family
family yeah yeah i think so
and your dog is like a little soldier
like yes sir and like you know he runs
and like you know protects the family
and stuff
in other hood and i'm forgetting what
the number is but something like there
you know i heard that there were
19 ways to smile and i'm afraid i'll
never
know all of them because i've never
smiled at him
i'm a romantic clearly and i love what
you're saying ian about the types of
love
and i agree and i think you know and my
brotherhood
my book is dedicated to my friends the
family i choose i happen to love my
family
but friendship is really important all
these areas of love
but the type of love you're talking
about to him the type of love
that enables you to be all you can be
is the best kind of love of all and
i hope everybody watching and listening
to this finds that love
or has that love and cherishes that is
that like when you have all the loves
together
and like all seven loves you experience
with one person and people want that
like i don't want to settle for anything
less than that and then you can snap
your fingers and wipe out half of all
life in the universe
and you've gained all the love jumps the
infinity love stones i think people
are holding out for like all the loves
but like a lot of times
you don't see it unless you love
yourself to begin with sure you can't
you can't
you can't love someone else unless you
love yourself you ever see that movie
saving silverman
no it's where like there's three guys
and like what they're one friendship
is dating this woman who really doesn't
actually like him
and then they're like you don't even
love him and she's like there's many
kinds of love
and like she's a controlling nasty
person i love bets but then she ends up
really liking the crazy
like other friend and it's like i don't
know i haven't seen that movie it's like
a 20 year old movie yeah
i got the guy from american pine and i
think what's that guy's name and
the other guy steve's on i don't know
that they want all those loves i mean
all of those loves are great
but you know a woman actually generally
women choose love
over motherhood however much they want
motherhood
because love of a husband
your spouse is a is a different kind of
love and we don't
we call a romantic lover but i we i feel
like we really need a whole new
lexicon for this because it's a very
powerful love that's very existential
not to say that children aren't but it's
a different
kind of love you love your child and
then you set them free
if you're if you're doing your job right
right you prepare them for
life your partner is should be with you
till death do you part
i think i get it i think that what guys
need to do is maybe like you know women
are going to want like a rugged man so
don't shave you know get that guy's
beard going
but then they want somebody who's got
style so maybe getting like a nice
fedora or something
but they also want someone who can prove
their fighting skills so maybe a katana
yeah really big
and then maybe like some old school like
gentlemanly
you know dapper looks like a trench coat
fedora katana and
beard and uh that's exactly what women
are into and then you can show off your
katana skills you need a fedora my
friend
[Laughter]
yeah i was gonna say beanie works too i
mean i think you know you yeah don't do
don't don't do the katana trench coat
they're gonna take your
eyes seriously i'm scared there's a lot
of people who already do that that's the
joke
it's the fedora tipping but no women do
like
generally masculine men um
and that doesn't mean that they're toxic
there was a an episode of of girls which
i know must be your favorite show
oh yeah the best i mean you know
everything i mean wow
so i
sort of cringe watched it but i watched
it and sort of like because i i
want to understand all this culture and
this you know millennial group and
you know her line was you know she was
the voice of the generation so
it's the last scene of season two sorry
if i'm gonna ruin for you it's only
eight years old or whatever
um she's going through some sort of of
mental
breakdown legit and she and her
ex-boyfriend on it go on again off again
adam driver character is her
guy and she texts him something
and they were apart at this point and
you see him
jump up run down the stairs there in
brooklyn new york
down the stairs down the subway back up
the subway around the block running
running i mean
this whole thing right and he runs up
the stairs somehow i don't forget how he
gets into her apartment
picks her up in his arms
the end if that's not prince charming i
don't know what is
yeah but you know these movies and shows
where
like take a look at like your trope of
romantic comedy mm-hmm
the guy like goes lumen's house or like
plays the boombox outside of her window
that guy's gonna get arrested real quick
like these romantic comedies a guy who
does that goes to jail
and he's called creepy there was a video
that like
i mentioned the 10 hours of walking
through new york as a woman thing where
like one guy's like how's it going and
they're like so creepy
there's a viral video right now where
like a a young girl
is sitting at a table streaming and a
guy just like tries talking to her and
it's really awkward
and everyone's acting like it was the
apocalypse like this guy was a creep and
i'm like
dude it's just some awkward guy the girl
was a little young man that guy probably
shouldn't have done that
and that is an issue but i was thinking
just like there's there's a big stigma
around
literally talking to him in a public
period so how is there supposed to be
some romantic
i guess you know mad magazine said it
best mad magazine
a long time ago have you guys ever read
them a mad look at when
i don't know mad magazine still exists i
used to read that it doesn't but i loved
it yeah they had a mad look at and it
was a series of comics talking about a
certain idea
one of them it was a mad look at public
displays of affection it was hilarious
the one the one first panel was like
this tall chiseled man with a suit
and a beautiful woman and she's got her
leg up as he's leaning into her and
kissing her and everyone around us going
like oh the next one was the same
thing but a morbidly obese bald man and
a big fat woman and everyone was angry
and
and you know kind of pissed off so the
the
the fact of the matter is and this is an
obvious trope that exists on the
internet and
especially in the install forums if
you're a a weird-looking guy
or you're short and scraggly with a
weird voice
you can't say these things to women but
a tall chiseled handsome man
tall dark and handsome when he can walk
into him and he can say a lot of things
and they'll swoon
if it's a nasty guy they'll they'll
belch they'll or not belch they'll
they'll cringe or or vomit
and then you'll get in trouble so that
would be rude
so that woman doesn't deserve you if a
woman does that
so xnay on those women anyway
here's the thing about men the secret
power of a man
secret power of a man is it's all in the
personality
be decisive be thoughtful be
fun that's all you got to do i would
have
along those lines you were talking about
that text and that fantasy
show don't if if you're anybody boy or a
girl and you want to
you want to communicate love to someone
don't do it through text
maybe send a sentence here and there but
it's in the delivery
like you just said if you want to
express your love to someone do it with
your vibration with your words with your
the sound of your you know i i would i
would agree with you ian but i do
think that sometimes texts can be
appropriate like maybe you send like an
eggplant emoji and then the water
droplets and then the peach emoji
that will convey your emotions
don't do it i don't know if kids if
younger culture understands because of
the text social media text culture but
it is not the way to
to communicate emotions in my opinion
that's why you got to do emojis
emojis only yeah like the skull face
when you're laughing
yes that's what they do oh okay i avoid
texturing
crazy kids kids these days they use the
skull instead of the laughing face
i tried to navigate relationships
through text and i just destroyed my 30s
basically in my late 20s so now i've
kind of sworn it off i just if i get a
text and it's
i get agitated i just set the phone down
and ignore it and then i figure if i see
them again i'll talk to them and it'll
that's a good idea i like that so
what do you think about these dating
apps because one of the things i've
brought up before is that
when women were in uh you know before
dating apps before websites for dating
a men and women in college together
their dating pool was the same dating
pool for the most part right 20 year old
woman
no has the same social circle as a 20
year old man
so the likelihood of her dating someone
within her age range and at the college
is
high with dating apps the likelihood
that she's now going to pop an app and
find a 35 year old guy who's got a
convertible and an infinity pool
infinitely higher and so it's very
simple it's not that
the woman doesn't like the guy at her
school
it's just that she gets two text
messages one's the 20 year old guy who's
in her class and says hey we're gonna go
sit in the train tracks and like drink
40s
and then the other message she gets is
from the guy who's like hey i'm going to
take the the convertible down for a spin
and go to the beach and look at the
stars and which one she's going to pick
women have preferences so maybe someone
i'd rather take the 40. but i think
there's a tendency
because the wealthier guy the the
established guy
has more opportunities for fun
and excitement and adventure yeah
these college women are more likely to
choose that it just opened up the world
for them and it's allowed these older
guys to get access to younger women in
ways they couldn't before
sure so that means that guys who are you
know college age right now
gen z they're going to struggle in the
same way
in in a similar way to millennials in
that 20 year old
i was talking to a guy a couple years
ago he's like 24 and he was a virgin
and he had no idea what to do right
because no matter what the women weren't
interested in dating him he's a normal
guy he wasn't a creepy weirdo like a
regular guy and i was like bro i guess
at this point he's got to like walk up
to somebody and say hello i'd like to
you know nice to meet you i live in the
area or something like that and he's
like you can't do that
you'll you'll you're like you're crazy
if you do that no no so
okay please keep coaching him
all right we're talking guys like that
years ago so right i don't know i
remember his name so any guy like that
because really that's just an excuse
because he's too shy to go over because
you don't be rejected
i don't think so i think you'll you'll
end up on on twitter with someone
filming you
calling you a creep they'll post your
picture on instagram and say this creepo
is harassing me
they get points for it i said it's fake
yeah they get views they get likes they
get subscribers
those women are going to be alone then
so that's very sad but i think
that i mean look i i'd imagine the
average woman
would not do that right probably just be
like i'm flattered and have a nice day
yeah not but the but the land mines are
there no sure the land mines the
landmines over there for everybody
we're all afraid of something we're
going to say something we're going to
tweet something we're going to write
something we're going to say
on your podcast your youtube show
but we got to take risks in life because
we don't move forward
without taking risks and in fact
risk taking men are are attractive to
women
again because they make decisions okay
may i may you know may fail but i'm
gonna try i'm gonna do it
and that is actually very attractive no
woman
not every woman is going to be attracted
to every man i mean a man can come to me
at a party and
kind of say he's interested and i kind
of i don't find him a
you know whatever he's not for me i'm
not going to be rude to him
but it doesn't mean i have to date him
he may get rejected
i could do the same thing to a guy where
i'm not necessarily going up to him
hey dude i but you know that flirtation
you start talking and then i could sort
of see he's looking over my shoulder and
which is not so hard because i'm little
and just not be interested in me and
that'll hurt my ego for a second and
then i'll move on
you know dating isn't easy you have to
take risks
and when you take those risks you're
going to end up with probably a woman
that you really want to be with
because that's the woman you were
waiting for and he risked a lot for and
he got rejected for a lot
people you know people well why do these
guys like they're not cute or whatever
it is
they always like you know hit on the
women well yeah because they're used to
rejection
what's one more the good-looking guy you
know with everything going for him
he's rarely rejected so when he sees a
woman he really likes he's
too shy to go up to her because he
doesn't want to feel rejected because
he's not used to that
there's another uh i guess you call it a
trope that
attractive women are less likely to
actually get
hit on randomly because guys will assume
they don't have a chance
so they won't bother and they'll go for
women who are like lower in the ranking
in their minds like less attractive
they'll see it when they're like wow
she's a nine she would never go for me
right that woman's a seven i'll i'll try
and head on her yeah
and so and i don't understand why you're
still single i mean you're gorgeous
you're doing so well in life i mean i
don't know well because
the guys didn't ask me out i mean i'm
talking about me specifically
but like you know yeah well that's why
we have so many women do so well well i
mean she's not going to say yes to me
you know well in fact guys give it a
shot again
women want to know that they're that
they're admired that they're like that
they're being courted that somebody's
interested in them
show you're interested it's actually
really attractive and yeah it doesn't
mean
all the time you're gonna get the right
feedback that you want
okay you move on i went through when i
was kind of
going through that phase where i stopped
talking to really hot girls not stopped
talking but i wouldn't hit on them or
like
try and get together with them because i
thought they probably get hit on all the
time
so i don't want to be one of those guys
so i would just completely and it'd be
girls i really
was attracted to but i wouldn't because
i was like i'm not going to contribute
to that
toxic masculine i was like you know 2007
feminist propaganda ian
it was i've had two guys in my life who
i really liked
who like you know five ten whatever
years later
you know like i really liked you but i
was just a little too
i just didn't i'm i didn't ask you out
or
what and i was do i was just dying for
them to ask me out
right so guys take a chance ask the
woman out please
yeah the worst case scenario is that you
end up on some
reddit where they're blasting your face
calling you a creepo out of context
yeah likely all of us in this room have
been in a reddit
conversation like that we are still here
to talk about it
oh yeah i mean me like every day it's
hilarious so now you have something to
talk about on the date
they're going to take this this is going
to be one of the best episodes for the
the grifters because
there's so much to take out of context
that's brilliant
yeah that's why i said you're welcome
when we were when we were talking about
the you know the women
struggling to find men who make as much
money as them like when i
when i did like two segments
in like two days because there was
another story that came out of similar
that was similar
feminist twitter exploded and the
funniest thing about it
is that these single women working for
you know these news outlets
immediately went for attacks on my
masculinity saying
you know just insulting me and insulting
things that that i guess would be
offensive to someone based on
stereotypical masculinity or whatever
and i would just like i'm laughing my
friends are like so there's other
youtubers like messaging me sending me
the screenshots and we're like just
laughing crying it's hilarious
because i don't think they realize that
like
i don't i i don't care like if i cared i
wouldn't make youtube videos
like heaven forbid someone who actually
cared about being made fun of on the
internet would actually put themselves
on the internet
i guess there's a lot of people who work
for these news outlets particularly
feminists and leftists who can't handle
it
it's like dude if you don't want to be a
public figure don't do it
man i chose to do all this i find it
hilarious what are they possibly putting
down about your masculinity
no they just do things like they do this
to everybody they'll be like you can't
get laid and they'll say you know like
just you know things like that because i
met your girlfriend and she's gorgeous
and a body i'm saying okay i'm sure i
i i'm not worried about you and your
masculinity but i don't care
and no i i know you don't care but it
makes look this is their content this is
this is what they do whether they're
paid for it or not this is the type of
content that they like to write about
this is what they know
and it's heartbreaking for me because
i i want them to be loved by a man
and i want them to love a man they say
incel right so
one of my favorites is uh are you
familiar with carl benjamin i don't
think so
carl benjamin of the lotus eaters
podcast by the way he's uh
anti-editarian he used to make a lot of
anti-feminist videos
and they call him an incel all the time
a direct attack on his masculine he's
like haha you can't get laid
he's married he has children right same
thing with ben shapiro they're like ben
shapiro's an insult he's like he's got
how many kids does he have now three
three
yeah right what are you talking about i
don't think ben shapiro is insulted by
your attacks on his masculinity he's got
a wife who's a doctor by the way i heard
her
yes and he has three kids so why do it's
really interesting that they do this
that like one of the attack vectors for
the this particular ideology is do do
they
maybe it's a caricature you know they
constantly say there's toxic masculinity
and these men are toxically masculine
so because of that they think men will
be insulted if you challenge their
masculinity or like
maleness or whatever you want to call it
they could be projecting
um you know in general millennials and
gen z
are not having um certainly gen z
they're not having
sex um as much as gen x
then i don't not referring about me
because i wasn't either
but in general they're not having a lot
of sex partly because they are
just on the apps or they're too lazy to
actually get off the couch instead of
sex
actually have real sex i am sure i'm i
don't know i'm not a man
i'm sure that it's much more satisfying
for a man to actually have
sex with a woman than to sext her from
his couch
yeah right yeah chances are right so
i look women
as much as women talk about that you
know they
want to have sex like men they just oh
they're gonna they're just gonna hook up
the hook-up thing
truth is women don't really want to have
sex like that
most women do not want that it doesn't
feel good
to you know for a guy just get out of
bed okay well thanks
women have all these chemicals that are
floating around that make them feel sort
of depressed afterward if they don't
feel that connection long lasting way
so it could be actually that they're
projecting
but whatever it is it just seems like
they um they're talking about the things
that they want most and that fear is
stopping them
from getting what they want i think it's
projection uh there was a story that
came out
i think about a year ago that i can't
remember what it was but it was like the
amount of
men under the age of 29 that were
virgins like skyrocketed by like 30
something percent
yeah and it was like 15 or so for women
meaning women were still able to get
laid but
not with men who were 29 and younger and
so a lot of these
uh socialist types and woke leftist
types who are active on twitter are
younger
you know we we've uh one of the things
that that's come up in conversation with
some of these individuals on this show
is that we realize they're in their
early 20s they're in their mid-20s
they don't have the same political
experience so we're having conversations
about war and conflict and taxes they're
like i don't know occupy wall street i
was you know 15 years old or whatever
it's like oh
real interesting so you and there's
things about the 90s that i don't know
because i wasn't you know i was a little
kid back then so somebody tell me about
clinton on stuff they're older
so a lot of these people on twitter who
are like democratic socialists who not
and they're not all in their 20s right
but there's a high likelihood
that they're all virgins and because of
that
they feel particularly insecure because
that makes them feel bad
they think saying it to me makes me feel
bad
or ben shapiro who's got children
the hardest proof of not being an incel
literally
conception but they're hurt by it so
they use it thinking it'll hurt you
and it's one thing to say oh well you're
probably a virgin still virgin like you
sound like you're like you're in
high school or something um i mean just
that tone of voice not that high
schoolers are
many high schoolers i hope are virgins
but incel
which is like a dark version of
a virgin version of virgin
meaning they're not necessarily virgins
right they just decide that they don't
they're not involuntarily involuntarily
so something happened where they're
unable and it can become really really
dark
and it can be a lot of these people
could be outwardly dark or inwardly
meaning
some of these people blame society and
blame everybody else and some of these
people blame themselves and think
they're just wrong and ugly and
incapable
yeah well yeah and
we were talking about girls who really
are are mean to other girls social media
um you know because toxic masculinity is
a man
you know punching a woman toxic
femininity
is our girls sort of bad mouthing each
other
or being passive aggressive and not
liking the photo
you know like girls are mean in other
ways
um but the fact that they're mean to men
is sort of like why are you doing this
what don't you have other things to do
like this is not a productive you know
thing to do with your life
so yeah guys get off the couch get off
twitter
get off twitter get off everything and
and go ask a woman out on your date
here's the trick yeah here's a trick you
have a dog
no no okay if you're a guy you need a
dog okay yeah here's what you do
yeah you go down to the beach you have
the dog
and there's some you know like women and
you know they're like hanging out and
then oh no the dog
he got a felicia oh rufus oh no i'm so
sorry
he just loves people what's your name hi
i'm tim nice to meet you thank you this
is rufus
correct this is how you do it guys for
the most part women
are not going to destroy you if you ask
them out if you flirt with them
and you know what you should know if a
woman doesn't seem like she's interested
like move on right like don't harass her
i mean we have to understand that but
also women like if a guy is
if you think he's interesting at least
for a conversation like don't
don't decide you have to marry him if
you go on a date with him
it's okay and by the way dating is fun
gosh you get to go out with somebody
you've never met until recently
and you get to learn about them you're
likely to learn a little bit about
yourself
maybe you'll have a nice glass of wine
if you're lovely you'll
you'll won't be upset if he actually
points to
how about this bottle of cabernet
sauvignon
and you go on from there enjoy life this
is life enjoy it i got some advice for
people who feel like they're stuck in a
rut
um go to a mma training gym
maybe it's not good advice because i
don't know much about mma trading gyms
but you can go to like a martial arts
gym i i used to live near one and maybe
you're out of shape
maybe you're a homebody who plays video
games you're lost you know what to do i
assure you if you walk into one of these
places
and say i feel lost i lay around playing
video games i want to do better
these guys in there are going to be like
dude right let me show you how to throw
a punch
come here join the crew we're going to
make you and and it's gonna be a whole
lot of fun
for me skateboarding was always this i
would just show up
everyone's having a good time you meet
people you'll be sitting down but then
i'll tell you this
whatever it is you choose to do in terms
of physical activity and community
and and making yourself better some kind
of physical exercise
you're going to encounter that challenge
so for me skateboarding right you want
to drop in on this big vert wallet scary
you're freaking out i assure you
you fall down from like your first six
foot drop in
and hit the ground and you're sore and
you're okay though
when you're out at the park and you see
you know a woman or whatever you're
gonna be like
i just took a face full of you know
concrete
someone telling me have a nice day is no
big deal so
you build that companionship with
through community by going to
some kind of gym and just sticking with
it yeah and
people like i assure you man most people
at these places are super excited to get
people involved and and help them out
and there it's it most people are good
people
and then you build confidence in
yourself by accomplishing something and
improving yourself
and then you can be calm and polite and
go and meet people whether it's a a guy
or a woman or you know just to be
friends
or to find a relationship it just starts
with the job you want
start that company you want women too
and if you don't if you're not ready to
go to the gym because of covid
and you just there's so many free
youtube videos like
i i mean amazing stuff out there you
know
just start a lot you know weight
training is really good it's good for
cognition it's good for how you
feel just start moving and
but you know you know what the big thing
is is being at the gym
with other people totally because
they're the ones who are going to like
one day you don't show up and you're
gonna get a phone call and they're like
bro
accountable what are you doing
accountability is huge i actually have
two
girlfriends i met at the gym i was going
to the gym before cove at six a.m every
morning
had these two girlfriends and we became
friends then this happened so we would
text each other i'm doing i found this
this class online i found this now i've
got these people i used to you know do
we were in a co-work space together
now we we countability every day we say
okay just did 40 minutes cardio oh i
just did yoga i just you know wait
okay and we give each other literally
the star emoji because that's cool
so but accountability is really good so
find yourself accountability friend
accountability coach somebody
who you can check in with and they don't
have to be better than you at whatever
it is
just a buddy that's a good point i was
playing music was mine and singing
because it would get re i would get
ripped my core would get rip when you're
like hitting
high notes and like like brandon boyd
from incubus i mean when you're like
doing that you get powerfully muscular
in your core
but the confidence doesn't come until
you have a communication
friend like a drummer like when you're
in a band and you're
you're exhausted and you're in you're
interacting with someone then when you
see a girl
it's you just do the same thing you've
been doing you're not stressed
because you've already figured it out
but when i was alone singing
i would still i would still be stressed
because i didn't have the communication
friend right
but that's partners shows are similar
book a show and then you're standing in
front of you know 70 strangers and
you're like oh man and then you
got to do it sure and but in that point
about you and the drummer right
that's you're you're better at you when
somebody else is in your life
when somebody else you know you need
that connection you need that
you that that energy back and forth i'm
sure the drummer felt great
because as you're sneaking and he's
going your shoes go i mean that's
that's what creates amazing music and
amazing connections
amazing relationships somebody just
chatted uh eggplant water droplets
peach and get it ian speaking my
language
all right let's take super chats if you
haven't already please
smash that like button because it really
does help the channel
and go to timcast.com become a member to
get access to a massive library of
exclusive
segments you know for a lot of the
members only stuff we do have
conversations that are very evergreen
talking with people about old war
stories
or old journalism stories or religion a
lot of talk about
religion faith and dmt and stuff and
like because i think we're all very much
interested in like
what else is out there so that's all
available at timcast.com click the big
members only button on the right you can
sign up
we got major upgrades coming to the site
soon so thank you all for being members
and again
smash the like button let's read some of
these super chats we got a
bunch of super chats because i think
everybody has an opinion
i can't read the name of this first
super chat because youtube blocks it for
some reason
they said hey tim i'm having trouble
with my math homework hope you can help
if man plus explain equals mansplaining
then woman plus complain equals
overreacting
is that right that's correct yes it's
it's uh it's it's femsplaining yeah
femsplainer yeah
yeah that's the podcast with danielle
crittenton and
and christina hoff summers who i see
yeah they embrace it
they do there's also you know you know
those man spreading
yes femme bagging oh interesting with
all our bags
yeah when women put their bags on seats
and block them and they don't move it
right there was a really funny post by
aaron rupa from vox i guess he's mad
that
ron desantis sat with his legs spread
in a chair that it was socially
distancing i'm like
i don't care if he puts his leg over his
head you know puts his foot behind his
head
he's in a chair six foot away from
anybody else why are you yeah why can't
he be comfortable i'm sitting
cross-legged right now
you know the funny thing is about all of
these like but i guess it's
mostly feminists who are like why do men
sit with their legs open
and then male feminists who are just
trying to like play kids women are like
i know right these guys are so dumb
and i'm like come on bro yeah you don't
like sitting like that i know it
right i guess you got tiny balls
whatever right yeah
that's the weirdest thing that guys
would hopefully admit that the real
reason though
is uh um q angle the the hip ratio to
legs so you know women have their have
wider hips so their legs kind of go
their their the femur goes inward
whereas men have narrower hips so their
legs go out and are more comfortable
it has to do with the thigh muscles but
also you know
junk it's not the patriarchy trying to
take our space
that's true no yeah that's not true that
was a question
but think think about the the mentality
people have where they genuinely believe
guys hit their legs open to just oppress
them like a guy sits down and he's like
opens his legs ha ha women you have to
be pushed now and they're like
he's pushing his legs against me you can
just be like excuse me you can move your
legs and they'll be
sorry about that all right trip suck
says my parents don't get it
bitcoin and ethereum will be like visa
and mastercard someday
i wish i could have bought tim coyne
when i started watching you in 2015 it'd
be worth millions now
tim coin yeah it's coming down i don't
know about that
maybe though um not tim coyne but we
were talking about so we wanted to do
this
you know well you're working on the open
source project versus expansion
yeah creating like a subscription
plug-in for people to have their own
version of like an in like a
subscription service
and integrating it with crypto so that
existing social media sites that use
crypto
could automate subscription services
through that so
yeah it's an idea all right let's see
what do we got oh account dankell what's
he doing toggle447 says count dankula's
running for
legislation across the pond he's going
to be on two separate ballots just
figured i'd inform you he's running for
legislation
what is it he's running for a position i
don't know what position interesting he
should win
virix says there is a german word for
the banality of evil
amstrak translating as bureaucratic
language
ah meaning company policy or orders from
above world war two criminal adolf
eichmann used this term saying it made
our jobs easy
wow that's creepy
rogue nerd lifestyle says hey what
you're doing is really important i saw
the video on inflation
can i suggest you talk to mike maloney
he has a series called hidden secrets of
money that drives into monetary history
so this is way off the conversation but
have you guys been seeing what's going
on with the inflation lately no
not not just inflation inflation but
shortages
so uh for those that are watching we we
ordered a new machine for this show a
new computer
it's delayed why is it shortage or
they're it's the certain parts are
unavailable so we have to wait
lumber is up 250 percent in cost steel
is skyrocketing
yes if you had 10
worth of lumber i think in like november
last year last year
it's worth 60 right now jeez six times
yeah yeah so imagine if you bought
bitcoin in november when it was at 15k
it's at 57k now wow that's not
that's not necessarily a good thing for
people holding bitcoin the people who
are holding bitcoin
their their buying power stayed the same
the people who are holding us dollars
are seeing their ability to buy
collapse that's freaky now ethereum whoo
i remember remember we had bill here
from bill for mines bilemon
and he was like i don't know if he said
it on the show or at some point he was
like
you should get aetherium yeah and i was
like okay and so i did and now it's at
2700.
it's just getting started i'm not giving
anybody advice on what they should or
shouldn't buy i will mention too
i don't know what's going to happen with
precious metals but i definitely have
precious metals
and i'm glad i do i like copper i like
it because it's so cheap
and it's amazing you can do stuff with
it yeah
yeah so i bought silver copper and gold
more copper than anything but that's
just because like your worst case
scenario is you can do stuff with it
yeah hammer it down make plates out of
it make wiring out of it
useful yeah make a crown all right
tin man says first time super chat i
appreciate what you do but going off the
rails
and suggest a book x heroes superheroes
versus
zombies novel by peter kleins it's
superhero zombies and zombie superheroes
cool but are there zombies and
superheroes involved in the book
see this is what boys like to write read
rather so
let's suggest this for boys i wonder if
that is one of the big
issues with like woke movies when
it's the hero's journey yeah right so
maybe it's something that
for for whatever reason young men longed
for to be a run-of-the-mill
moisture farmer on you know what what
planet was tatooine what was it
and then all of a sudden the old wizards
like it's your father's lightsaber and
you're actually a
magic warrior and it's like whoa now
we're going on an adventure and
i the reason i think that works is um
also the reason why i think x-men worked
when i was when i was growing up the
story of x-men is like you know as soon
as the kids hit around 13 years old they
develop superpowers
and so as a kid you're like oh man it
would be so cool to like all of a sudden
find out you have superpowers wow
so the kids can relate to this or not
relate to it but
it like in a sense relate to it yeah
like an alter ego
but now you have these movies like
captain marvel where like who relates to
that
to like robbing a guy in his motorcycle
you know i don't know if you saw the
movie
yeah but it was just not
a hero's journey in any capacity like so
there was a great comparison someone did
between captain america and captain
marvel
captain america was the scrawny brooklyn
kid who had all these defects and
couldn't get in the army
and then shows like good moral character
and gets a super soldier ceremony comes
great
whereas captain marvel was a hot shot
pilot who just was
accidentally got superpowers and then
was kind of a dick about it
you know all right smooth play johnny j
says hey tim i am a financial advisor
and recommend the following
if you're going to make a major purchase
in the next few years take the funds out
of your investment now while the markets
are still high
interesting that comes from smooth play
not me he is the financial advisor he
says
american capitalist says the treatment
of boys is a piece of the piece to the
puzzle
but so many of these experts have a good
grasp on one issue
and aren't seeing the big picture the
big picture on a societal scale is far
worse than most realize
and what is it that was it that was it
well
all right the food oh
rush list leader says having children
for a man is too much of a risk because
if a man is not ready for a child
they want to pay child support whereas a
woman doesn't have that
they do but it's not as typical
women do have to pay child support i
think it was um russell brand divorced
katy perry is that what happened yeah
and he was entitled to like a ton of
money he was like i don't want a need
for money i'm rich you know what i mean
right
it's like i don't need it dude he's a
sage muscle brand
yeah he's all right he's cool dude i
like him i i think he's
i i you know i think he's i think he's a
good dude but
he's not rusty as his name would rust
suggest
ryan pujoy
i think the real issue is not that men
aren't driven per se i think the issue
is that because of these laws more men
just don't see what they will get out of
a family sense
the price uh since the price of divorce
can be too high
right right but but we did talk about
all
all the reasons why you love allison so
amman ra al ghul says going through a
divorce currently with a feminist that
took advantage of my weak mental state
before i went through therapy in dealing
with ptsd for more
i'm scared for my daughter's maturation
what we had um we had a guy on the show
like one of our first guests actually
yeah we need to have him back what was
his name
sean smith sean smith and he said don't
date feminists
yep and we were like really and it's one
of our most viewed videos
evergreen that's right wise
uh all right we got some criticism for
you jay rich says tim love your show
however steam is coming out of my ears
listening to melanie's third wave
feminist propaganda
please get rolo to massey or rich cooper
on the show and have the same
conversation with them
maybe it would be interesting to have
someone a different opinion and we could
have a fuller conversation happy to do
but i think i'm i'm not
the third i mean i don't know why i
think i'm sort of saying the opposite
stuff like i'm saying the more
traditional stuff i'm not saying the
feminist stuff i'm saying i love men
i think women want to have children i
mean i'm
but not fourth wave feminism which is
like the men are bad in the patriarchy
third wave
there's a lot of waves i guess i don't
know how many waves there's four i don't
know
what's the first wave uh women should
vote yeah yeah
and then what's second women should work
sixties seventies
the gloria steinem betty ferdan by the
way betty for dan who wrote the feminine
mystique which is really like the book
that kind of set off
the feminist movement she actually in
their second edition had to say
okay but no no i didn't mean in lieu of
l love marriage and children i meant
added value
we could live to our potential and you
know i
love your husband and have children it
was like but it became
no no no it's let's just eschew love
marriage and motherhood
and go for the career which was not
what she meant by it and kind of what
happened
at the end of the 60s is the sort of
decisive idea of
no no women need to be men or like men
and that's how women will smash the
patriarchy
and meanwhile but the truth is most
women
want love and partnership marriage
and children not all but some most
we got a correction here for me ill
machiner says al loved his family
every time he got the chance to run off
with a model he chose his family
yeah i watched married with children
when i was
little obviously not understanding a
whole lot of it like remember no ma'am
where all the all the guys would wear
the shirts that says no man it was like
after it was like the feminist symbol
like a line through or something no
ma'am
and uh he my understanding of it the
message i got
was not that he chose his family because
he loved them it was because of like
guilt and like he was a coward it was
just
a really awful show he was so mean to
his wife yeah
they both were mean to each other this
is an awful show a dysfunctional family
it's really funny
i used to have like leave it to beaver
this wholesome family where they ate way
too much for breakfast like massive
pancakes what did you throw that all
away i guess business was a booming back
in the day
and then it's like we got in the 90s
dysfunctional families i will say
malcolm the middle was legit
because they were dysfunctional but they
all really did love each other they were
great yeah that show was good
i love them well of course my generation
well in the 70s
80s well we had one day at a time
divorced mom
two teenage girls we had um kate and
allie
two divorced women who lived together
with their daughters
um the 70s girls saw
that women you know were divorced for
because the husband usually ran off
the quote-unquote secretary and they had
to take care of the kids and so they
were living life one day at a time
so it was this sort of feminist view
that we can do it on our own
i don't know i'm sure that that had a
lot of effect on the way that women grew
up knowing they could
do it on their own but again i
and also the women sometimes married in
order to leave their their
parents house because they couldn't earn
enough money
to pay rent at all i don't know i think
that
certainly cultural what we saw on tv has
an effect on
on the way kids think about their future
video games too
yeah i mean talk about the hero's
journey and indoctrinating people to
think there's an enemy to
just kill or slay out there and that
everything's gonna be okay once they do
it
now we we did have that criticism but
this one uh caleb w says guest
is based af family law is moving forward
through myself and three of my friends
have won custody of our children
in ga because we provide a better life
for the child i don't know about other
states also got my tim foil hat gorilla
shirt it's super soft
aren't they super soft yes it's amazing
now some some people
uh have asked about like taking care of
it because you know the shirts
the the way many shirts are printed they
don't last that long
i'm not entirely sure about these shirts
because i've had no problems with them
they're actually really nice
but i guess you're supposed to wash them
inside out is that correct that is
correct yes
wash them inside out there you go when
in doubt wash inside out
dragon noodle soup gaming says hey
melanie you might get a lot
from going on to honey badger radio a
prominent mra group
i'm sure brian martinez and alison
tiemann would would love to have you on
yeah well what so when do i get
cancelled
i don't know i'm okay yeah i think it'll
be all right okay all right
steel fang says cinderella didn't go to
the ball to find a prince
she went to get away from her crappy
life
prince can help her do that i guess but
yeah well i mean no she went because he
was
there because i didn't she in any case
the point is if she didn't get married
she would not have a future
yeah she went the fairy godmother turned
her into a princess
yes no that was after then i was over
and then she went to the ball and then
he met her there she didn't have a
prince when she got there right
oh maybe no no they met they first
because of her status
he meets this really sweet girl in the
forest or something is that the real
story
and what happened i met this is the i
remember seeing this on broadway
and and he's so like wow this little
peasant woman is
so sweet and oh lovely and then she's
the princess
kind of looking it's not a princess but
in the ball gown
and he doesn't recognize it's the same
woman and she leaves the shoe
and he finds it's her and then realizes
oh this is the kind woman
and by the way this is why i i'm
actually pro princess
um not certainly megan although i don't
know but
no pro princess because princesses are
generally
very kind kind to animals
lovely they and or badass like i hate
that term why did i say that
because it's true like wonder woman yeah
right yeah strong yeah there are a lot
of good things about princesses
all right i don't know how to aum and
uh um and uh okay okay that's what it
says i'm enough
thought this lady was going to be whack
at first she ended up being a great
guest
thanks thanks thanks
sydney says mgtow what do you think
about you know mg towers men going their
own way
meaning that they don't want women they
just want get a dog and go to the woods
i mean if that's what's good for them
but again i mean or
they could find somebody that enables
them to live
to their potential because of their love
for them
i i think that's great however if they
don't want to be with someone
then that's their choice but again i
think
if anything maybe somebody to play the
drums while you're singing
there you go civic nationalist says both
me and my girlfriend are part of gen z
my girlfriend is not political in any
way whereas here i am i've been with her
for two years and we intend to marry
young people need to understand is work
out
uh uh yeah yeah run five miles every day
build on a skill wake up early i do this
absolutely yeah good well that's why you
know one of the things
i've always loved doing is i guess i'll
just say action sports i've been
skateboarding for a few decades
but recently i've been rollerblading and
we just got some bikes and we're gonna
get scooters
because i'm old you know when i was
younger skateboarding was hanging with
my friends and we all did it
now i'm more about trying to get as many
people as possible to come and be active
and and do things so
having a wide variety of things to do be
it skateboarding biking rollerblading
scootering
i'm even down to like get some pogo
stick people in the house and apparently
there's somebody who's like a really
good pogo sticker who might
end up coming and like doing some crazy
pogo tricks that's cool
but i just love the idea of goal
oriented exercise
where when it comes to the action sports
you're not just like i'm going to do
five push-ups or you know 10
you know sit-ups or whatever you're like
i'm going to land a 360 flip
and then it could i tell you man trying
to learn that new trick and it takes you
like a hundred tries and you're drenched
in
sweat because you're trying to attain a
goal
it pushes you way harder than being like
i have to do 10 pull-ups
what if it was like you have to do 10
pull-ups you had to climb to the top of
a mountain
like you you know where your goal is you
can't stop until you get it and it wears
you down that that i love
so that i i always recommend
skateboarding persistence and resilience
are very good things matthew medic says
men aren't aren't seen as career
obsessed
it's like it isn't a common arc in
movies books and songs
is that the man is at work and not being
with the family
oh i see you're saying it is like a
common trope where like
you know i like click you see the movie
was it called click with adam sandler
he gets a clicker that can control
reality and he starts using it to skip
over
family boring stuff so he can go he can
stay at work and then it starts
automatically flipping through his life
and he regrets it
it's kind of a dumb concept i guess you
know whatever i'm like what is her what
does it click or that can do anything
have to do with
skipping your family life i don't know
but there's like scrooge
you know he was a dick she wanted to
like make money and then he realized his
heart grew
three sizes or whatever because the
ghost told me go to hell and you didn't
want to go to hell
oh christmas carol yeah that one you
know she's right
do you think i actually care about
people or was he just scared you know
because like
death was like i'm gonna kill you and he
was like i'll do i'll pretend to be nice
he loved the girl and then and passed on
it or something that's right
and he remembered and then when he and
then love came back
yeah they were they were in love and
then he chose career instead
and then he got to see the ghost the
christmas past was like look at what you
had and you gave it all up
there's uh i was watching the simpsons
and uh
i don't know what episode this is
because i barely watched simpsons but mr
burns
falls into a fountain and he gets sucked
through the jets
and he's getting repeatedly lands in the
water and then he says i wish i spent
more time at the office
the joke is nobody says i wish i spent
more time at the office when they die
[Laughter]
eric miller says tim can you talk
uh can you talk about alien invasions
and doomsday politics
oh tim you can talk about alien
invasions in doomsday politics but love
is sacred men
to men love is playful to women love is
work even when women have everything
it's still just a business
great show that's heartbreaking ludus is
the playful love
it is one kind of idea i disagree with
that yeah
and by the way love relationships are
work yeah it turns out
yeah yeah joey martinez says hey tim i
reached out to
langley outdoor academy for your 2a
expert and he said he would reach out to
you guys as well
he's been hitting the pavement hard on
joe biden's gun grabbing
get that gun grabbing out of there we
need the opposite of gun grabbing we
need the government to be gun giving
yes just walking around being like
here's your gun sir imagine if there was
a guy would like knock on your door
and then you'd be like hello and it's
like i'm here from the atf you're like
oh no why i'm here to give you a gun
yeah not take them away heck yeah i
don't know about you but i'm very proud
i didn't get my stimulus gun yet
stimulus gun no right where's mine
instead of giving people money because
money is devalued due to inflation wow
give everybody a gun yeah standard issue
i don't know glock 17 or something sure
yeah let's go mil spec air 15 556
sure sure
all right what do we got here darth
salad the tosser
says if we continue down this feminist
path why get married
just let it all fall apart and women
will become property again
okay well we know where you're single
[Laughter]
yeah that's fair dragon noodle soup
gaming says men shouldn't be sympathetic
to a group of people who have demonized
them
in all of the institutions and the media
while taking their children away from
them
because they're bolstered by divorce
court women need to do better feminists
need to do better yeah feminists
let's make that distinction right
because i'm pretty sure like most of
these conservative guys who are married
wouldn't say that about their wives
absolutely not you know
and their wives aren't working for
buzzfeed so
not writing about it either
slim 74 says great point about coved and
being at home
i've been your basic handsome uh i've
been your basic handsome weekend to get
laid
we are dating honesty man i've changed
my attitude now not sure how but it
worked
values found interesting very cool yeah
okay oh here we go i i got the married
with children people mad
g says tim you're absolutely wrong about
married with children
it it taught an important lesson don't
quit when the times get hard
they never left each other regardless of
how much they drove each other crazy
that's fair
but like imagine having
a media tell you that it's not enjoyable
to do
and then you're like why should i change
my circumstances now now to be fair
the simpsons had the inverted message
where when milhouse's parents got
divorced
and then mouse's dad what's his what's
what's his character's name
yeah he's showing home or the bachelor
pad and he's like
i homer sleep in a race car do you sleep
in a race car and homer goes
i sleep in a big bed with my wife and
then he's like oh
yeah that was great i love it i sleep in
a big bed with my wife
even homer got married
patrick in chicago says human
relationships are designed to model the
trinity
man and woman or even friends united by
the spirit of god
like the father and the son each seeking
the best interests of each other before
themselves
that's what we crave and brondo is what
plants crave
slim 74 says a woman that appreciates
making her man happy with feminine role
is what men want
take care of your appearance treat him
good
all right we got some economics image
jpeg says
inflation answered by austrian
economists tim
ian or luke if he's watching i implore
you to read murray rothbard's america's
great depression
central banks own most of the auag
keeping prices low luke hit me up and
he's like bro
move to florida oh yeah and i was like
bro
no it's so hot it's so hot hot and humid
well my friend of mine i i was i was it
was a really cold april day in new york
city and i was just texted
a guy friend of mine i said it's so
freaking cold today he's like moved to
florida which was like out of nowhere
and i'm like
it's like you don't even care about my
hair i know right
exactly it's like you don't understand
what frizz is all right
no legs no problem tv says 50 of a
marriage divorce
of marriage's divorce 80 initiated by
the wife because she lost quote the
butterflies
the dad has two weekends a month with
the kids those are real stats
divorce dads beg for time with the kids
interview terence pop
see i mean no it's heartbreaking i i
mean i i'm with you i i think it's
heartbreaking all
and hey the thing is forget the couple
those kids need their dad yes especially
those boys
why why would women keep their unless
god forbid the husband with the
accessible via i mean if he was not a
good guy
but in general why would you keep your
children away from their father
yeah my parents got divorced
and they were very pragmatic
so i saw my dad almost every single day
he lived really really close
and my parents were just like when they
realized it wasn't working and they were
fighting all the time they were like
divorced right and they just how old
were you
i think i was 13. do you have siblings
yes
older younger all older all older yeah
so you're the baby
so so but you had
older siblings who also kept you feeling
safe i bet
like no no okay no i was uh
yeah interesting chicago upbringing i
guess
well i mean i'm my parents divorce well
they separated when i was 14
divorced when i was 18 my mom died when
i was 19.
but i was very like you know i'm not
going to let this
ruin my teenage years my parents almost
split up
um and then they decided to stay
together kind of for financial concerns
for the kids
and then they end up getting separate
bedrooms and their their relationship
blossom works
they become better friends is that it
that's kind of cool kayaking together
and stuff wow there you go
this one's really kayaking this one's
really important
damien maddock says feminism was created
by the federal reserve
telemeon it was created by the federal
reserve so there's a lot of a lot of
problems in society
i don't know people were chatting like
ian didn't say federal reserves
absolutely
i will though all right here's a good
one though golden uh golandaz
thop says you guys are not talking about
the role of grandparents
in eastern cultures when both parents
work the grandparents take care of the
children
the west also confuses passionate love
versus stable love
passionate love is very temporary that's
interesting
very true no that's true and and
yes we we have to think about love for
the long term
and things change and people change we
get older and all of that stuff
and we have to love each other for
reasons other than just
attraction certainly and i don't even
think that is level there is one of the
secrets
yeah we need arrows plus you know it's
like hbo plus you need like
yes all right mark zuckerberg says ian
is my wife's boyfriend
the uh what no zuckerberg
maya culpa says sometimes things in life
are too heavy to carry alone
marriage helps divide the burden by two
life is just
one part hardship and one part happiness
trying to complicate it
and that's true and i mean you brought
up jordan peterson i mean suffering is
is part of the meaning of life i mean
suffering is something that we deal with
as being humans and it's okay to suffer
it doesn't mean you failed at life and
it doesn't mean you're not lovable
it's okay to suffer austin smith says
hello tim fool
please shout out my band guile and grit
we released our music video for our song
hurt people today
also when you start having bands we'd
love to perform at the beanie compound
that is
absolutely possible but you called me
tim fool so you're banned
i'm just kidding send us an email
in fact because you called me tim fool i
think we will have you
no i'm kidding send us an email back
all right what is this dell men's says i
hope you can reach out to joker from
better bachelor
bring him on as a counterpoint to this
gal i think
i i want to point something out a lot of
people are mentioning they're like you
got to bring on these guys to talk about
these issues too and that's a really
good point men and women have probably
have different perspectives on this
probably and so i think a lot of people
i will say
a lot of people have probably heard a
lot of male perspectives
on these issues so you know having a
female perspective on it is good and
then actually having both
yeah well i mean i sort of have a male
perspective on this but i mean like a
more
someone who specializes in these
conversations and the data and the
research that i don't
sure i think that's good and i do think
that i
give a different perspective one of your
yeah i don't think it's a very typical
perspective i you know i do in that most
women think like me
but the narrative is sort of left
feminist all right justin stowers says
unfortunately tinder social media taught
women
that everyone wants to f them so they
feel they can have anyone
now even the undesirables only want a
6'5 rich guy with rock hard abs and a
ferrari
normal guys just say effort while we
wait for them to settle for what's
reasonable
well normal guys like the average guy
doesn't have to do that
they just wait till they're 35 and they
have money and then they are the guy
who's got the ferrari or whatever
there's also nothing wrong with rock
hard abs that's right and you can
actually have them
anybody could it's called exercising go
to the gym
meet some people i'm telling you man
yeah you don't deserve to be settled for
whoever this guy
is i hope nobody ever settles for you
but maybe you shouldn't settle for the
way you feel right now and to your point
go do mma the reason why i said mma gym
as opposed to like a regular gym
yeah regular gyms where you're like you
know you pay a membership
people are just there to get their work
out in real you know forever time and
they're not there as a community
but like an mma gym i would i would
assume in my very very limited
experience that people are training
towards a goal
and there's probably a community there
of people who show up to hang out they
know each other
but there's also parkour gyms there's
also skate parks you go to any of these
places
you go to you go to a skate park and
you'll see a couple guys hanging out and
if you've never
skated before and you walk up to any
random group of people and say hey guys
i've never skated before they're gonna
be like oh dude let me show you
everything and they're going to be so
excited to do it
and you'll make friends so the
camaraderie that comes along with action
sports
there's not like everybody wants to
teach people
it's like it's almost like proof to
themselves that they have value and
power
so if you're some like average
skateboard dude hanging out at a park
you probably skate all the time you
probably get somewhat bored unless
something interesting is happening or
your friends are you know going on a
mission
as they call it and then someone comes
in they're like would you mind like
showing me how to do stuff it's like oh
i got something to do like
let me show you how it's done buddy now
it makes you feel good because these
these skaters or these people feel like
i've got something of value that people
want from me right and then this
and then you go in there you make
friends and then i tell you
like you you count the days you've been
skateboarding and then in like three
months when you're doing tricks you get
your first kick flip they're gonna be
cheering and clapping and like jumping
up and down for when you
when you land those tricks talking about
giving people purpose man when you let
someone teach you
that's what a great purpose you're
giving them yeah
well again it's dynamic in dating like
i'm not saying that the man is going to
be teaching the woman although
everybody can learn something from
somebody else but again
just the fact that he has a passion for
wine or a passion
he's a foodie and wants to show you the
restaurants he loves or whatever
don't say no you know i don't want to go
all the way there can we just like hang
out and like
just like grab some bur like give him
the opportunity to show you his passion
just do it and if you're not interested
that's okay too and
again i want to go back to the subtle
guy please don't live
life passively waiting to a point where
you think
that a woman is 40 and she's going to
settle for you because that a that's not
going to happen
and b you've missed out on your life
you're settling on life
no woman's going to settle for a man and
no woman is going to want to be with a
man
who has settled that that's yeah could
you imagine
being with a woman who's like just mad
every day
because she's settled like why would you
want to be in a relationship like that
women don't need to settle like
women because we have jobs we can pay
the rent
that's this magical thing right we it's
true that we don't need a man to pay the
rent
but we want a man that's good that's
better
we're not marrying you because we need
you we're marrying you because we want
you
all right samuel pyle says i'm 19 and i
put 1k
into doge at 3 cents and if it reaches
35
i will be a millionaire and thank you
ian i bought one kilogram of graphene
this is the future i am a gorilla yes it
is you can also get your official our
pillow
you can see it in the chat it is it is
pinned you can also go to timcast.com
click the shop button
and we have the our pillow you you're
familiar with my pillow correct of
course
well we have the better communist
version i thought it was going to grab
the our pillow me too i was
really thinking that totally yeah
because he looked at the pillow's right
there but he said ian was grabbing the
graphene
no that that's the one we actually sell
the burlap one we didn't i like that
our pillow see all right the maya's
crossed out because this is
a good communist feeling i see it's
collective
that's right it's a burlap sack full of
styrofoam packing peanuts
it feels awful to this guy about
graphing we were just talking about how
the cost of wood has gone up
six six times 600 percent and steel is
increasing
250 but they're saying now like in the
same article they said
a piece of lumber that was ten dollars
of selling for 60 now yeah so i think
graphing
maybe a potential future uh hedge
against inflation if we can start
producing this stuff
super cheap then we're not going to need
lumber and steel like this
and they may pull us out of the but
graphics graphing by the way graphene i
know is like a great super conductor
but is it are they going to make like
multi-layered graphene sheets that are
stronger than steel or something yeah
well uh you can yeah and you can make if
you take two sheets of graphene and
twist them 1.1 degrees you can create a
superconductor that way
apparently it's stronger than steel i
would like to see it in practice
because the body of a car you could also
allow it with things to make it even
stronger like aerogel
skydragon says growing up i was always
told that i needed to make sure i went
to college and got a good job
so in the event my husband left me i
could support myself and my children
it was never a drive for career
achievement true
yeah true yeah oh yeah i remember i was
it was the 70s i was let's say seven
years old pigtails
and my neighbor the dad asked me what i
want to be when i grow up and i said
i want to be a psychologist and he said
oh that's nice but it really doesn't
matter because you know you'll
you'll grow up you'll get married and
you you won't have to work your husband
will take care of you
and i remember this putting my hands on
my hips going
and what's going to happen when he runs
off with his secretary
how will i be able to take care of my
children
now of course this was part of the
cultural conversation that i learned
but the truth is that again a positive
part of feminism is that
let's say he didn't run off the second
dose he died let's say he's sick let's
see got hurt on the job
i mean a woman has to be able to take
care of her children and herself
i think that it's okay it's wonderful
that women are a
able to earn a living and able to earn a
living on par with men
and able to live to their potential
i i find it way hotter when a girl can
take care of herself
than is needy i don't like yeah
personally i don't want the cling
i don't blame you mr house says many
young females of this era want the
benefits of both feminism and
traditional relationships but none of
the struggle
as long as this cherry-picking behavior
continues both sexes in western society
will suffer
oh there's a struggle there's a struggle
if you are
36 years old and the guy you love and
thought you were going to marry breaks
up with you
i have to tell you that is
if you don't know now if you're going to
have children because now you only have
a few more years
of their struggle all right let's just
read this uh one more from
seoul invictus he says women do need to
settle early
because those are their peak years and
if they don't because of fomo
because of fomo men age like wine women
age like milk
don't pretend women will be fertile
forever and men have to prove themselves
to be valued
do i look like milk no thank you
that's a fair point i would just say
that
it's true men do age well however
women are aging even better women are
taking
better care of themselves and can
take good care of themselves and
hopefully
a man would love a woman who takes care
of herself and would love to take care
of him too
right on well ladies and gentlemen
thanks for hanging out on this friday
night
we're going to be chilling this weekend
filming more episodes of the vlog we're
going to be
it's cast castle we haven't seen it
already and we're going to have uh
eventually we're going to get into doing
it
every single day because we are
genuinely crazy here going to be turning
and turning the studio into a reality
show i guess but as a vlog so whatever
make sure you follow us on instagram at
tim cast irl and on facebook at
facebook.comcast.irl when you follow us
and click that like button on facebook
you can share the videos
that way we can get more people to go to
timcast.com and become members
because we're going to be rolling out
new shows a newsroom
and i'm really excited for this
paranormal show that we're getting we're
working on
you know it's a it's a snowball rolling
down a hill so it starts off slow but
once we get to the point where we have
like the key managerial components we
can start launching these shows
faster and faster i'm actively talking
with talent
you know creatives about their own shows
and things like that so we're gonna have
a bunch of really awesome stuff on
temcast.com
i'm hoping that eventually it'll be like
a one day a big
you know site with a whole bunch of
movies and shows original content
so that's common and it's all thanks to
everything uh you guys do for us by
being members by just
subscribing to the content that we give
to you you give back we can do a lot
more and i really appreciate it
don't forget you can follow my other
youtube channels youtube.comcast and
youtube.comcastnews
this show is live onto friday at 8pm and
we'll be back monday but uh melanie is
there anything you want to mention
social media website
yep please follow me savvy auntie
s-a-v-v-y
a-u-n-t-i-e on all the socials except
clubhouse where it's my name
melanie notkin n-o-t-k-i-n
and uh hoping to continue the
conversation
there yeah you can follow me in
crossland.net and at ian crossland
throughout all the social media accounts
thanks for coming guys it was really fun
it was fun i had a lot of fun this is
the kind of conversation that i thrive
i love this stuff me too me too good
friday night
yeah and then me and the corner pushing
buttons i was just listening i
absolutely loved this conversation thank
you so much for coming melanie
thank you for inviting me sour patch
lids on twitter you guys may follow me
there as i try to outpace sour patch
kids for followers
thanks for hanging out everybody we'll
see you all again actually
i'm sorry we're going to have clips up
from earlier in the week we do this on
the weekends so there will be clips
tomorrow and sunday
but on sunday over at youtube.com
youtube.comcastcastle
we will have a vlog where mike jumped
over the tesla on his bike
it's not the biggest feat in the world
especially when you realize like you got
people like travis pastrana jumping over
buildings or whatever he's doing
but uh hey we're trying and we're
getting things going so make sure you
check out youtube.com
castle subscribe to the new channel and
we'll see you all next time
you